this is Jocko podcast number 80 with
echo Charles than me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening takis Oh
lay among the corpses there were
thousands of them the whole world's gone
crazy
he thought dimly a man might as well be
a dead leaf floating in the autumn
breeze he himself looked like one of the
lifeless bodies surrounding him he tried
to raise his head but could only lifted
a few inches from the ground he couldn't
remember ever feeling so weak how long
have I been here
he wondered flies came buzzing about his
head he wanted to brush them away but he
couldn't even muster the energy to raise
his arm it was stiff almost brittle like
the rest of his body I must have been
out of here for quite a while he thought
wiggling one finger at a time little did
he know he was wounded with two bullets
lodged firmly in his thigh low dark
clouds shifted ominously across the sky
the night before sometime between
midnight and Dawn a blinding rain had
drenched the plane of segi Kihara it was
now past noon on the fifteenth of the
ninth month of 1600 though the typhoon
had passed now and then fresh torrents
of rain would fall on the corpses and on
tetazoo upturned face each time it came
he'd open and close his mouth like a
fish trying to drink in the droplets
it's like the water they wipe a dying
man's lips with he reflected savoring
each bit of moisture his head was numb
his thoughts the fleeting shadows of
delirium his side had lost
he knew that much cobia waka hideki
supposedly an ally had been secretly in
league with the eastern army and when he
turned on a sheet of min-koo saris
troops at Twilight the tide of the
battle turned to he then attacked the
armies of other commanders ukita Shimazu
and Konishi and the collapse of the
western army was complete in only half a
day's fighting the question of who would
henceforth rule the country was settled
there was Tokugawa Yasu the powerful Edo
daemul images of his sister and the old
villagers floated before his eyes I'm
dying
he fought without a tinge of sadness is
this what it's really like
he felt drawn to the peace of death like
a child mesmerised by a flame
and that right there is the opening of
the novel called Musashi by eg yogi
shower and a giant novel and it's about
the life of Miyamoto Musashi the
Japanese swordsman from the late 1500s
and early 1600s and he's probably the
most famous swordsman from Japan and I
apologize for my pronunciation of
Japanese names I'll have to work on that
but Musashi which is a book we are going
to cover we're not covering it today
we're going to cover it in podcast 100
that was decided upon when Tim Ferriss
came on the podcast we're gonna cover
the be novel Musashi
and again Musashi was a swordsman
probably the most famous Japanese
swordsman he was born into a samurai
family around 1584 and there's a lot of
questions around his upbringing but the
reports are that his father was a very
tough and demanding samurai and then at
some point around age 10 his father was
either killed or something else happened
and he basically disappeared now Musashi
fought his first duel at age 13 against
a grown man who he killed by throwing
him to the ground and then beating him
with a bokken which is basically a
wooden sword and he fought multiple
battles defending the Toyotomi clan
which is he was aligned with and he
continued to fight these duels amassing
more than 60 wins now some of these
duels are to the death some of them are
they actually agree upon what they're
going to do before they fight
and he won all the ones that he
participated in and his most famous duel
was against a guy named kojirou also
known as Gahan drew and he was the the
biggest rival of Musashi and they were
both at the time when they fought like
the most famous and feared swordsmen in
Japan and then after that he went back
and he's a warrior so he went back he
continued in combat he had a few more
duels after that and most of that his
life and and how that went up until that
final duel is portrayed in this book in
its historical fiction right there's not
that much truly known about his life and
so this book that's written by eg
Yokogawa yoshikawa sorry it's it's a
huge book and like I said we're gonna
cover ton podcast 100 and when we cover
it by the way
spoiler alert um that's why we've been
telling people since podcast number 50
because the book has one of the most
astounding endings of any book and this
thousand-page book you've made all
builds towards this final ending which
is literally on the last two pages it
like the ending happens in it's over and
it's awesome and it's worth it but
before we cover that book I thought it
would be smart to cover two things that
Musashi actually wrote himself so after
that duel that famous duel with kojirou
he became a retainer for some Royals and
he was you know basically a warrior on
staff and as he got older he ended up
writing but the first thing you wrote
was a book called the book of five rings
which is really famous everybody knows
it it's correctly translated order
alternative translation is the book of
five spheres and another thing that he
wrote was the del koto which one of the
translations is
the way of walking alone and we'll get
to that but first we're going to talk
about the book that this famous
swordsman actually wrote which is pretty
cool
when you think about it so let's dive in
to the book of five rings going to the
book I've set my mind on the science of
martial arts since my youth long ago I
was 13 years old when I had my first
duel on that occasion I won over my
opponent a martial artist named ARIMA
keiki of the new school of accuracy you
like that you like that Inu that's the
name of the school the new school of
accuracy at age at 16 years of age
I beat a powerful martial artist called
Akiyama of the Tajima province when I
was 21 I went to the capital city and
meant martial artists from all over the
country although I engaged in numerous
duels never did I fail to attain victory
after that I traveled from province to
province meeting martial artists of the
various schools although I dueled more
than 60 times never once did I lose that
all took place between the time I was 13
years old and the time I was 29 when I
had passed the age of 30 and reflected
on my experiences I realized that I had
not been victorious because of
consummate attainment of martial arts
interesting statement he's like I wasn't
victorious because of my supreme martial
arts perhaps it was because I had an
inherent skill for the science and had
not deviated from natural principles
they may also been due to the
shortcomings in the martial arts of
other schools in any case I subsequently
practice day and night in order to
attain an even deeper principle and
spontaneously came upon the science of
martial arts I was about fifty years old
at that time so looking back and I feel
the same way when I look back at my
military career I think of all the
things that I could do
much better now when we were if we wrote
if I would had the right extreme
ownership when I was a task unit
commander I wouldn't have been able to
put together side and have all that
knowledge I couldn't see it and so I had
to actually go through it and then look
back and reflect on it and then I
understand my own lessons better and
they actually become more clear to me
you know with every day that goes by I
understand a deeper principle of what I
originally thought worked and I
understand them more clearly since then
I have passed the time with no science
into which to inquire trusting in the
advantage of military science as I
turned it into the sciences of all arts
and skills I have no teacher anything so
he's taken what he learned from the
military and from martial sciences he
just applies it to everything he doesn't
have any other scientists don't need him
yeah now in composing this book I have
not borrowed the old sayings of Buddhism
or Confucianism nor do I make use of old
stories from military records or books
on military science again I love this he
doesn't quote other things he doesn't
he's not pulling quotes and using them
he's just he's using his own words with
heaven and and Canon for mirrors I take
up the brush and begin to write at 4:00
a.m. on the night of the 10th of the
tenth month 1643 I had to include that
because clearly he's he's up before the
enemy even though he's a retired soldier
50 years old he's actually he's older
than that 1643
he's quite on a bit he's up early and
he's writing this stuff now and again
it's amazing you can sit here and read
what he wrote in 1643 back to the book
martial arts are the Warriors way of
life commanders in particular should
practice these arts and soldiers must
know this way of life in the present day
there are no warriors with certain
knowledge of the way of martial arts
imagine he's saying that
when there's literally samurais in
existence in Japan and he's like these
guys don't get it imagine would he be
saying right now today first let us
illustrate the idea of a way of life for
the physician healing is a way of life a
poet teaches the art of poetry others
pursue fortune-telling
archery or various other arts and crafts
people practice the ways to which they
are inclined develop individual
preferences few people are fond of the
martial way of life first of all the way
of the Warriors the way of warriors
means familiarity with both cultural and
martial arts even if they are clumsy at
this individual warriors should
strengthen their own martial arts as
much as is practical in their
circumstances so he does say that a
bunch you've got to be familiar with all
you know obviously focused on martial
arts but you've got to be familiar with
the culture walls as well people usually
think that all warriors think about is
being ready to die as far as the way of
death is concerned it is not limited to
warriors medic ins women farmers and
even those below them know their duty
are ashamed to neglect it and resign
themselves to death there is no
distinction in this respect the marshal
way of life practiced by warriors is
based on excelling others in anything
and everything I like that and that is
actually what Uncle Jake in the book way
the warrior kid tells young mark what's
a warrior a warrior is the one that's
doing his best in everything that he
does so I'm down with Musashi on that
one whether by victory in an individual
duel or by winning a battle with several
people one thinks of serving the
interests of one's employers of serving
one's own interests of becoming
well-known and socially established this
is all possible by the
power of martial arts yet there will be
people in the world who think that even
if you learn martial arts this will not
prove useful when a real need arises
regarding that concern the true science
of martial arts means practicing them in
such a way that they will be useful at
anytime and teach them in such a way
that they will be useful in all things
clearly I subscribe to this and that's
why extreme ownership of the book we say
all the time it's applications to the
battlefield to business and to life all
but all all the same it's all the same
back to the book the field of martial
arts is particularly rife with
flamboyant showmanship with commercial
popularization and profiteering on part
of both those who teach the science and
those who study it the result of this
must be as someone said that amateur
istic martial arts are a source of
serious wounds so do we see this today
yes we do we see it across the board we
see it with actual martial arts schools
in the modern sense of a martial arts
school and we it's that's being beat
down a little bit right now right
because because we have MMA we have
jiu-jitsu we can actually test and you
can't just run around doing acrobatic
kicks that aren't actually functional
yeah that magic one that you do yeah
yeah or the Dimock where you're going to
like - I'm going to touch your neck and
you're going to fall to the ground yes
so that stuff has been pretty pretty
crushed by not only by MMA but also by
the interwebs yeah the whole hill has
fought against that remember that
website I think it's a lot boo-boo
bullshit oh yeah yeah yeah legit cuz
they just go through show everyone
that's full crap yeah yeah the bullshit
oh guys they've been around for a long
time - that websites been around for a
long time
boos I think the bullshit Oh calm yes
and they show everyone that's that's
full of crap right yeah hey if I settle
my Chi's aim my Chi and I can knock you
out right and people actually paid money
for that stuff yeah and it's crazy how
the guys who go to debunk it they'll
like you see actually one on one where
the guys will go to the dojo and be like
hey I'm not skeptic you know do your
thing to me and knock me and the guy
will be like okay and then they'll
they'll follow through with it let well
I mean everything he'll Rogan and I were
talking about that that situation that
just happened in China where the Tai Chi
guy went into an MMA guy and got
obviously got destroyed yeah because it
doesn't work yeah and that's nothing new
this I don't know and you know what I
said on that I mean that kind of stuff
is I think those kind of martial arts
are supposed to be more like yoga you
know about stretching it's about
movement it's about proprioception it's
it's fine to do that's cool but it's not
going to stop somebody from doing a
double leg on you like a stick something
on from throwing a four punch
combination at your head yeah yeah train
guy who holds one arm and just beats you
down with you yeah and then and then the
other part of this is you get the guys
that are out there you know talking
about the mental mindset of the special
ops and all that and it's like they're
trying to sell magic yeah same thing
anything the flamboyant this is what you
need to do is like be tougher how's that
yeah yeah how about you give that one a
crack but they want to sell the
flamboyant busier flamboyant showmanship
and and you know you can sell the the
though you can sell the people's
weaknesses right it's all about like the
mystery yeah the masti yeah all the
mystique you can stall the people's
weaknesses you know if you remember the
old scene you might have to be old
enough did you ever read soldier of
fortune magazine you're a kid no I know
what that is yeah but when I was a kid
you know I was interested in war yeah
all soldier of fortune I get my hands on
a copy I read it and there were key
things in there you know devastating 14
moves that you learn and you will never
lose a street fight and people would say
yeah you know that's cool I'm going to
order this this the VHS tape mature
it'll have the solutions
and you just you know if they are not
applicable yeah that's generally not
ethical now of course if you teach
someone some aggressive movements that
they're gonna do and they're gonna
memorize those movements and then they
do it to a person that doesn't know how
to fight yeah and tree actually they
what those movements can be effective
I'm gonna punch you in the head 17 times
you know you come up to me and say hey
you got a problem that I punch you in
that 17 times yeah with no warning like
that that actually okay yeah where I put
the person down and then I ran away
that's right it works but it didn't it
you know when somebody came up and
squared off to me or we had a real
legitimate situation it's not going to
work yeah your false sense of security
is isn't gonna help you out there you
know so I think it's very interesting
that in 1450 you know yeah we're dealing
with this or what it knows now starting
on fortune 52 1643 we're dealing with
the same stuff human nature doesn't
change it's true all right going back to
the book in regard to the warrior Knight
that path involves constructing all
sorts of weapons and understanding the
various properties of weapons this is
imperative for warriors failure to
master weaponry and comprehend the
specific advantages of each weapon would
seem to indicate a lack of cultivation
in a member of a warrior house I will
illustrate the science of martial arts
by likening it to the way of a carpenter
now I think this is important because
it's telling you that no matter what
your business is you've got to get in
the game you've got to know the various
tools of the trade whether that's the
business world whether that's
construction whether that's no matter
what you do you need to open your mind
up don't be scared in and study what it
is in your craft and you are get these
guys these young seal officers and they
be embarrassed that they didn't know
something about a radio or they'd be
embarrassed that they didn't know
something about a sniper weapon and I
would just say look when you don't know
something you go up to the sniper and
you say hey man can you get can you give
me a familiarization on that weapon or
you go up the radio and say hey can you
teach me how to program this radio
because I don't know how to do it
that's what we're talking about here
instead of just ignoring it or
pretending or trying to hide from it get
out there and ask them and believe me
the sniper and the radio man they don't
look down on you because you said to
them can you show me how to do this they
look at you and say aw cool he's humble
and he wants to learn I'm here let's
make it happen
so now going back to this this idea of
the of the carpenter as an example back
to the book when sorting out timber for
building a house that which is straight
free from knots and of good appearance
can be used for front pillars that which
has some knots but it's straight and
strong can be used for rear pillars that
which is somewhat weak it has no knots
and looks good
is variously used for door sills lintels
doors and screens that which is knotted
and crooked but nevertheless strong is
used thoughtfully in consideration of
the strength of the various members of
the house then the house will last a
long time even knotted crooked and weak
timber can be made into scaffolding and
later used for firewood now what I like
about that is from a leadership
perspective guess what that means that
means you look at your team and you're
going to have some strong squared away
looking individuals and squared away
acting individuals they're going to be
part of your team and you can have some
members your team that are not so
squared away they got some knots in them
and a little bit crooked and what you
have to do is you have to learn how are
you going to use them where you gonna
put them they can still you might have
someone that's strong a little rough
around the edges they're gonna be a
supporting pillar not the pillar that
you're gonna put out front which is the
nice clean-cut look in the individual it
was also sharp so as a leader you have
to do that you have to get what you can
out of all your out of all your pieces
of wood I love the idea from a
leadership perspective the idea of
looking at it as a as being a carpenter
because there's a couple different
things not only do you have to learn how
to use these different tools of
leadership so there's all these
different tools that you use in
leadership there's all these different
ways of communicating with people and
and how you interact with people and you
have to learn all those different tools
but then you have to learn that you need
to use the tools differently on
different human beings because they're
going to take a different reaction to
them and then the different types of
human beings actually have individual
personalities so it's exactly like
woodworking in the fact that you've got
not only do you have different types of
wood but you also have different types
of wood that has individual issues like
if a piece of birch is a lot different
than a piece of eBay eBay is hard hard
wood eBay I think it has a burn rating
that is higher or the same as concrete
think about that the marketing usually
thing in the water it sinks I got a deck
made out of an eBay it's awesome just
it's a very hard wood but you can't use
you have to use a different tool you
have to use the tool differently then
you would with a piece of pine which is
very soft and that's the way people are
- that's where human beings are you have
to know how to use the tools and then
you have to learn how to modulate the
tools correctly with each individual
piece of lumber yeah you see it all out
in like team sports like in football for
example you get a guy he don't know he
doesn't know how to do anything you
can't teach him he's I don't know
whatever but he has a hard head you know
yeah he's just down for the cause that's
it it's like thanks seemingly useless
you put him on special teams you put
them on the kickoff are you gonna make
him a wedge breaker there you are wrong
best wedge breaker in the game yeah get
some exactly back to the book speaking
in terms of carpentry soldiers sharpen
their own tools make various useful
implements and keep them in their
utility boxes obviously same
correlations there back to book I've
written this book in five Scrolls
entitled Earth's water fire wind and
emptiness and this is the true science
cannot be attained
just by mastery of swordsmanship alone
so you got to get more and I think it
was on the first Tim Ferriss podcast I
was on I think he asked me what was the
most
complicated mission that you did knows
like hey the missions aren't complicated
was complicated is dealing with human
because that's the hard part that's the
hard part of leadership yes it dealing
with shoot the machine gun I mean
there's some skill to it but it's
infinitely easier than trying to lead
men in combat back to the book the way
to do battle is the same whether it is a
battle between one individual and
another or a battle between one army and
another you should observe reflectively
with overall awareness of the large
picture as well as precise attention to
small details the large scale is easy to
see the small scale is hard to see to be
specific it is impossible to reverse the
direction of a large group of people all
at once while the small scale is hard to
know because in the case of an
individual there's just one will
involved and changes can be made quickly
this should be given careful
consideration so you can see a big group
when they're trying to turn you you can
you can know then but with this one
individually you're not really
understand sure what they're thinking
then he talks a lot about this he talks
about a lot about the elevation and how
you have to step back and look at things
from different perspectives and also I'm
gonna make this note right now he's got
these little lines at the end of so many
of his paragraphs like this one this
should be given careful consideration he
says those kind of things a lot and I'm
not gonna do all of them but I'm
definitely gonna give enough to give the
feeling of the book which is very it's
very instructional in the way it's
talking to you which I dig back to the
book um this is interesting back to look
unless you really understand others you
can hardly attain your own self
understanding that's at the opposite of
what we normally think we know I got to
know myself first and then I can
understand other people he's saying you
got to understand other people and then
you then you get to understand yourself
and I think that's very useful because
we should see ourselves in other people
we should let other people say I know
what they're doing I I do that too
yeah back to the book in the practice
of every way of life and every kind of
work there's a state of mind called that
of the deviant even if you strive
diligently on your chosen path
day after day if your heart is not in
accord with it then even if you think
you're on a good path from the point of
view of this straight and true this is
not a genuine bath if you do not pursue
a genuine path to its consummation then
a little bit of crookedness in the mind
will later turn into a major warp
reflect on this mm-hmm right that's
great advice and you know what you know
what that makes me think of is when
people ask me which they ask me a lot
about joining the military yeah you know
I want to I want to join the military
when I go in the SEAL Teams I want to
support the country that's awesome but
you better make sure that you're doing
it because it's a true path to your
heart if you're doing it for some other
alternative reason it's not it's going
to be a work that'll show up later now
doing four years at four-year hitch in
the Marine Corps the Army in the Navy
and the Air Force is going to be good
for you and it's not like it's a light
permanent lifetime thing and it'll
probably teach you a lot but if you're
going to do something you've got to
remember that you sign that dotted line
and you might be going to war yeah and
if you have that if you're not doing it
for the right reasons you're going to be
you're not going to be a happy person
when you're over in in the combat zone
it's not going to happen so stay true to
your path and make sure that the path
that you're on is is something that you
really want to do something you really
want to believe in yeah or something you
really believe in now musashi fought
with two swords a longer sword and a
short sword that was kind of his
trademark inand it's easy
I think he's credited with creating that
form of fighting and both some other
samurai carried two swords like a
primary to secondary but he used two
swords simultaneously which is pretty
legit
so back in the book the real thing is to
practice the science wielding both
swords the longsword in one hand and the
sword short-sword in the other
when your life is on the line you want
to make use of all your tools no warrior
should be willing to die with his swords
at his side without having made use of
his tools however when you hold
something with both hands
you cannot wield it freely both right
and left my purpose is to get you used
to wielding the longsword with one hand
so know your tools practice with them
here we go the longsword seems heavy and
unwieldy to everyone at first but
everything is like that when you first
take it up a bow is hard to draw a
halberd is hard to swing in any case
when you become accustomed to each
weapon you become stronger at the bow
and you acquire the ability to wield the
longsword so when you attain the power
of the way it becomes easy to handle
what's that saying it's a in practice
and it's also saying the same thing that
one uncle Jake told young mark hey
you're not going to be good at this at
first of course you can't do pokes you
haven't practiced them of course you
don't know your timetables you haven't
practiced them and it's the same thing
in any job that you're in you have to
practice it
it you're not just born you're not just
born programmed you have to program your
mind hmm
work you have to do back to the book in
my individual school one can win with
the longsword and one can win with the
short sword as well for this reason the
precise size of the longsword is not
fixed the way of mine school is the
spirit of gaining victory by any means
and what I like about this he talks
about this more and I don't know how
much it might hit but he's got an open
mind even though he's very direct about
what he knows works he's also saying hey
look the sword got worried about the
length of the sword I'm worried about
what works and winning and achieving
victory by any means necessary
that's an open mind
in the martial arts of my individual
school it is the same for one man as it
is for 10,000 as far as paths are
concerned and well before I go on past
that this is why for me it's very easy
to make these correlations because I
talk about all the time
the similarities between jiu-jitsu which
is a one-on-one match against another
human being and being on the battlefield
and the things that you're doing are the
same the combat principles don't change
you're trying to flank people you're not
trying to attack the hardened targets
you've got to know when to back off
you've got to know when to attack you
got to seize the moment all those things
are the same so Musashi realize this
obviously back to the book as far as
paths are concerned there are Confucians
Buddhists tea connoisseurs teachers of
etiquette dancers and so on these things
do not exist in the way of warriors but
even if they are not your path if you
have wide knowledge of the ways you
encounter them and everything in any
case as human beings it is essential for
each of us to cultivate and polish our
own individual path important and and
again I get questions about life people
want to make decisions about their life
and the answer is look go out research
but you need to cultivate your own path
you need to figure out and you can do
that you need to learn to educate and I
certainly answer all kinds of questions
about that but at the end of the day the
person that's signing the dotted line
the person that's going to you know drop
out of college so they can join the
military or drop out of there sometimes
I'll get hey you know I want to start I
want to leave this job to start my own
business right those are the kind of
things the big decisions and you gotta
you got to make that
be responsible for that decision yeah
that I can give you some perspective and
my perspective is you know for those
you've got to know if you're in the
military you better know that that's
truly what you want to do for leaving
your job that you don't like anymore
because you want to start something new
set things up set up an exit strategy
plan for it suck up the job that you
don't like while you're saving money
while you're getting a landing place
ready and then slowly you know make your
transition win it when the time is right
yeah don't just get frustrated one day
quit yeah and then you're sitting there
with no income no way to get anything
started then you're desperate yeah any
when you're desperate things aren't
going to go well it's not good to be
desperate yeah and you hear that that
romantic story where you know this guy
did that you know it was part of his job
so he just up and quit and landing god
that's pretty you know economists tough
yeah and what's that bias that you get
what are the only people that you hear
about are the ones that actually pull it
off availability availability bias so
that's what happens we only hear about
this guy right at quit his job and
started this thing in his garage and now
he's a billionaire yeah yeah well but
there's a lot of people that never made
it out the garage there and they ended
up in you know a job that yeah more and
worse
yeah or went back the next week begging
for their job back and they got a small
demotion back to the book in
distinguishing the advantages of the
tools of warriors we find that whatever
the weapon there's a time and a
situation in which is it it is
appropriate absolutely listen to this
you should not have any special fondness
for a particular weapon or anything else
for that matter okay
too much is the same as not enough to
entertain likes and dislikes is bad for
both commanders and soldiers pragmatic
thinking is essential I mean just just
insert that open your brain and put that
in there
what's so often we get the little likes
and dislikes
you know we're you don't want a pet
peeve of - well the word pet that that
bothers you and there's nothing I would
saw Charlie plum last this past week
yeah and I was telling him about that
one of the biggest things that I took
away from sitting and talking to him
with that whole idea that if you do
something that annoys me it's my fault
yeah it's my fault feel being annoyed no
it's my fault for being anointed I need
to get fixed yeah
so if I have a pet peeve that echo
littlez's pan around that's not your
fault
that's my fault I need to get over it
yeah as long as the Pens not clicking
pecking then it's our problem right
that's but that's so important and to to
think about this we do we have in it we
have we like sinks and you know what we
generally like what we're good at
yeah right take about jiu-jitsu yeah
what what do i what am i Donald so
guilty of this I'm like um I submitted
14 people today khmer khmer khmer pek oh
yeah right or geeky eating right I don't
open my brain up enough yeah guard pass
one side oh yeah guard pass one side
only that's the week I got to break that
yeah I got to get more
I gotta get less fondness for a
particular weapon that's such good it's
because almost because it's so hard
that's such good advice yeah also let me
think about everything even like you
know you probably have your favorite gun
you ever favorite everything really I
prefer the I'm Fergie however for no key
I prefer this gun I prefer that you know
yeah hey got to be careful of that yeah
pragmatic thinking is essential now here
we go back to the book rhythm is
something that exists in everything but
the rhythms of martial arts in
particular are difficult to master
without practice harmony and disharmony
and rhythm occur in every walk of life
it is imperative to distinguish
carefully between the rhythms of
flourishing and the rhythms of decline
in every single thing the way to win in
a battle according to military
scientists to know the rhythms of
specific of the specific
opponents and use rhythms that your
opponents do not expect producing
formless rhythms from rhythms of wisdom
and this is just so classic and you
think about on the battlefield this is
what maneuver warfare is right this is
temple they talk about it in terms of
tempo when Brian Stann was on he's
talking about maintaining that tempo and
then what you need use you need to
maintain the faster tempo then your
enemy can maintain and when you can
maintain that tempo or you disrupt the
tempo or you disrupt their tempo that's
how you're going to achieve victory
obviously it's the same thing in jujitsu
I I'm keeping you know I'm pressing one
side pressing one side pressing one side
boom I disrupt I go the other side but I
just passed your guard you know I break
your tempo and even in fact ball or
soccer that rich in soccer that change
your pace you know you come down the
field going at a certain speed then you
speed up front of it and you change that
tempo that's how you that's how you pass
you know boxing too you know the whole
idea of a counter punch dance that yeah
what did Solow Solow read arrowheads
really famous sayings it um it's about
being late you know so like someone
basically out temple's you are out or
disrupts your pattern and then now you
have to catch up around your late says
when you're late you muscle when your
muscle your tire when you tire you die I
might have missed one but I think that
those looking those are pretty
straightforward oh yeah what you remove
it's true when you get someone off tempo
it's when someone has me off tempo but
are you chasing them yeah and hang on
and things are happening you don't know
it yeah and if he did if he does a thing
where he keeps the pace and he and you
man he just it's like he's pulling ahead
pulling ahead until you're like until
you die yeah here we go just straight
breaking it down right here back to the
book for people want to learn my
military science there are rules for
learning the art one think of what is
right and true to practice and cultivate
the science 3 become acquainted
the arts for know the principles of the
crafts five understand the harm and
benefit in everything six learn to see
everything accurately 7 become aware of
what is not obvious 8 be careful even in
small matters 9 do not do anything
useless if we could if everyone could
just do 9 not do anything useless yeah
think about that yeah about how powerful
that is web think how much useless stuff
that we do and less useless it's not
helping us yeah that's what we were
talking about I don't know maybe last
sermon title
a few weeks ago about distraction that's
really what it distracting excuses
useless but stop those the other the
other a couple of these understand the
harm and benefit of everything learn to
see everything accurately become aware
of nob what is not obvious those to me
are all about detachment you've got to
be able to detach from what's going on
to be able to see things accurately
you've got to be able to detach to be
able to see the harm and benefit and
things you've got to be able to detach
to be able to see what's not obvious and
the more caught up you are in your head
or in the chaos in the situation the
more you're going to miss those
important factors right there back to
the book first of all keep martial arts
on your mind and work diligently in a
straightforward manner then you can win
with your hands and you can get feet
people by seeing with your eyes
furthermore when you refine your
practice to the point where you can
attain freedom of the whole body then
you can overcome people by means of your
body and since your mind is trained in
this science you can also overcome
people by means of mind when you reach
this point how could you be defeated by
others so he's talking about you need to
refine your practice to the point where
you get freedom I think I might have
said something along those lines right
this way let's freedom all day long you
know
all day long refine your practice until
you attain freedom think about that
practice until you get free yeah you
don't just expect freedom you don't get
freedom by acting free know you get
freedom by discipline yeah so like
jiu-jitsu for example right you know
when you're a white belt brand new they
teach you the move here's the move
here's step one step two step three you
practice that enough times along with
all the other moves now you're just
jumping in there and flying with a fly
you know just going on almost automatic
right off you're just free to do
whatever move at whatever time you are
it's the exact same thing on the
battlefield if you drill drills and you
become your team your platoon your squad
becomes so fluid with them that they can
adapt and they can change them because
that's what we're really talking about
they have the freedom to move they have
every they know the rules so intuitively
that to become just part of the way they
act as humans it's like when you have
you ever been showing the move in
jiu-jitsu or someone's been showing a
move on you
right like let's say you're gonna you're
going to show the the the guillotine on
me and so you you pull me over and you
shock me down and as you shut me down I
counter it like not in not it not on
purpose because I know I'm just trying
to show the movie I like automatically
turn my hand grab your arm I know it's
like oh I can't do that right now I
can't counter the move but that that's
not my that's not my brain doing that
yes peer instant right there instinct
it's almost like you have to consciously
not if they consciously not do it and
then after you constantly not do it five
times the example you gotta like drill
it three more times just to make sure
you're good health because you didn't we
here we go back to look it is by no
means possible for me to write down this
science precisely as I understand it in
my heart so what that means to me is
what I talk about a lot is that we look
at different sources for the same
information we want to know about human
nature we want to know about leadership
we want to know about war no one has the
ability to just get it right so that's
why we come at it from different angles
that's what we do just like in jujitsu
when you learn an armlock from Jeff
Glover and you learn a lot mocking Dean
Lister they're gonna get you know
Jeff Glover will give you 82 points of
performance game Lister will give you 82
points of performance 73 of them are
overlapping but there's some 9 that are
a little bit different and that's little
that's where you make up and someone's
going to work you know some glover stuff
is going to work a little bit better for
me than it is for you but then some of
these stuff's gonna work better for you
than me but then some of those were
actually going to combine what both of
them say and we're going to end up
instead of 82 points performance we end
up with a hundred and sixteen and now
our blocks a little bit better yeah this
is deep go yeah so here we go pay
attention
the science of martial arts is not just
a matter of reading these writings
taking what is written here personally
do not think you are reading or learning
and do not make up an imitation taking
the principles as if they were
discovered from your own mind identify
with them constantly and work on them
carefully this is so critical and it's
like I say on the podcast for a while at
the end of the podcast I was saying
don't just listen do because just
listening doesn't help you you have to
go more than listen he's saying you have
to do more than just read and it's
interesting and we get people that are
really into either podcast that read the
book and I talk to them you know we have
clients that brought us on to help their
company and they love extreme ownership
and they are they feel like they're
fully on board and understand the
principles and all that and then you get
in there and you start talking to them
about what they're doing and they're
missing them yeah and it's because they
don't attach they look they're looking
out at everyone else they're not they're
not looking at themselves and it's it's
hard because they read them right they
listen they don't know what you do they
know it plenty they've got to do it yeah
so that's hard that's the catchment
comes it becomes important there are two
- did
that's from yourself and actually think
about what you're doing is very hard and
without doing just that you'll be
successful and I like how he says you
take these ideas and make them like as
if they were discovered in your own
brain how do you apply them to your life
that's one of the things that's so good
about the muster is because with the
interaction it's it can be hard for
people to birth these ideas from their
own mind like to take the seed that
comes from extreme ownership or comes
from the podcast to take that seed and
and and plan it and have it grow it can
be hard to do that they look at the seed
they hold the seed as sacred yeah right
but they're not putting it in there and
letting it grow and watering it when you
come to the muster what's cool about it
is you're you get you get to ask the
question and say hey what's going on
with this explain us to me and then we
get to give our perspective and now we
make a connection now that seed gets a
little little water on it fertilizer it
starts to grow and and also we you get
pulled out of your own head because when
you hear three other people's questions
that are similar to what you're doing
and then but again you can't just listen
to someone else's question to go oh I
see the answer that you have to say wait
a second what how does that answer apply
to me hmm too big deal
yep back to look in the science of
martial arts the state of oh man this is
there we go in the science of martial
arts the state of mind should remain the
same as normal in ordinary circumstances
as well as when practicing martial arts
let there be no change at all with the
mind open and direct neither tense nor
lacks centering the mind so that there
is no imbalance calmly relax your mind
and savor this moment of ease thoroughly
so that the relaxation does not stop its
relaxation even for an instant so you
want to remain calm so I used to come
and put myself on report here I used to
play this game with my
kids sure I would take the the inside of
wrapping paper you get that sword it's
like a cardboard sword yeah it's like a
cutting board tube it's like a giant
toilet tissue too right yes and I used
to play this game with my kids it was
called normal face yeah and I would line
them up and you had to keep your face
totally normal no expression it's not a
smile my life if you weren't didn't have
a normal face you'll get cracked with
the tube as almost gives the line up and
they would just get the most blank
expression on their face and I would you
know I'd do something to try and make
them laugh or try and make them startled
get scared what's that what's that word
when you flinch I try and make a point
like I might swing I'm in a flinch now
oh please don't even if it looks like I
was going to crack you right and now you
fridge now you get a crack head you
flick and it was there was a lot of fun
because kids because once you crack you
know one kid then the other two kids
laughter would line them up yeah good
but my goal in that besides to have fun
with the family you know cuz head trauma
and all that can be very fun for the
family sitting there's no head trauma
happen but it was fun to play and the
kids would laugh but also get them to
control their emotions right and you get
them to not be so readable to everyone
get them to control their emotions get
them to relax so you got to play normal
face with your kids sometimes good
jacques versioned it's good holidays
when you when you see a kid in a
frustrating situation and they got
normal face you know you're saying yeah
yeah good even when you see an adult in
that situation yeah you see the pressure
going on and they got the normal face
just looking at okay yeah okay oh you're
screaming and yelling cool normal face
over here yeah who do you guys want to
follow normal face guy or freaked out
guy over there
no not freaked out guy so yeah child
services
you know you can come and get me
but that's what those two things are
kind of for ya the way
they're made to crack your kids in the
head with them and have fun some kind of
cracking device yeah yeah well they're
just so perfect
ya know you know it's more perfect in
them is you can get the foam you can get
the foam that you use them to cover hot
pipes in your house
yeah and it's just little foam to this
those things are the best because you I
could literally hit you as hard as I
possibly could and it doesn't even hurt
at all but it makes a cool noise if the
eyesores with those that they just put a
little PVC PVC pipe at the end of it but
not the whole thing because that PVC by
yeah yeah as can i that doesn't have not
kind of basic but that's that's injuries
yes but you just put enough of that so
you have a handle so just a hand and
then you have this little pete that foam
and you can my wife the first time she
saw us doing it my wife freaked out I'm
in there I'm whaling on my kids because
you're doing full Barbarian like
overhead smashes with these swords as
hard as you possibly can yeah and it
doesn't hurt at all
at all those are good too cuz it does
make a little crack noise yeah they're
fully effect yeah does a flimsy though
no that's the thing they're surprisingly
they're not flimsy they were sink wising
we ridge it that's why they're so
effective for the normal face game that
it X norm ax face advanced yeah you
don't have that many wrapping paper
tubes so I'm like okay we need an
alternate here when you do alternative
yeah we need to keep this going yeah go
to the basin yeah just like coming not
with Home Depot or bottom those doing a
project at my house and then I had that
leftover and of course I'm looking at it
tube I'm thinking swords like a normal
face let's get it on then I've
discovered a perfect a perfect play
weapon there you go boom back to the
book
once you have sharpened your intellect
to the point where you can see wherever
in the world is true or not where you
can tell whatever is good or bad and
when you were experienced in various
fields and are capable of being
boov are incapable of being fooled at
all by people the world then your mind
will become imbued with the knowledge
and wisdom of the art of war isn't that
interesting
did you hear about how you get infused
with the knowledge of the art of war
it's by understanding people that's how
you get there
that's how you get there back to books
there is something special about the
knowledge of the art of war it is
imperative to master the principles of
the art of war and learn to be unmoved
in mind even in the heat of battle
normal face generally speaking it is
essential to make your ordinary bearing
the bearing you use in martial arts and
make the bearing you use in martial arts
your ordinary bearing this should be
given careful consideration so your
normal you should be normal all the time
that's how you should be whether you're
fighting whether you're in combat or
whether you're a dinner keep it
ordinary keep it normal he's talking
here about the focus of the eyes a
specialty of martial arts is to see that
which is far away closely and to see
that which is nearby
from a distance um you've got to have
that perspective that's why you don't
get drawn into like when you're when
your platoons got a mission you don't
get in the planning with them because
then you you'll be so close that you
can't see what it looks like from far
away well in martial arts it is
important to be aware of opponents
swords and yet not look at the
opponent's swords at all this takes work
this matter of focusing the eyes is the
same in both small and large-scale
military science it is essential to see
both sides without moving the eyeballs
so you've got to work that peripheral
vision again Officer Candidate School
you can't look at your food we didn't
know why they made us do that we thought
it was just torture
you can look at your food while you're
eating you got to look straight ahead so
why would they make you do that so you
improve your peripheral vision you
cannot look at your food try it sometime
yeah you have to develop your peripheral
vision and this idea of both large and
small scale military science being able
to see that which is far away closely
and that which is close from a distance
that's detachment you're embroiled in
that thing that's close to you you gotta
detach from it so you can see what it
looks like and the thing that's far away
you've got to get into it
you ever hear two people debating or
something not professional debaters or
nothing but they're arguing a point you
know one guy's point versus the other
guy's point and with debate a lot of
time comes interruption you know like
you're saying sorry I interrupt you
right and then every once in while
you'll notice one person say hey can I
finish you know you keep interrupting me
another guy might say well I'm just
saying you can end slowly that debate of
the two important issues get put push to
the side actually and the debate becomes
whether or not they justified or justice
justifiably interrupted the other person
so it's now about the interruption
that's like you know you say don't focus
in on these little details that come
come about in a in a big situation yeah
well what's really crazy they have news
programs
I'll see you like a clip of a news
program and it's basically three or four
panelists all talking at the same time
yeah it's the most ridiculous thing ever
yes that's another thing I think was Joe
Robbins was saying you know we were
talking about podcasts themselves yeah
he was saying the news people need to
learn from podcasts yeah that you don't
need to have people on for four minutes
three people four people five person
panel they're all talking at the same
time they're all looking to get that big
zinger
you know point across that they
pre-planned and then they try and drop
it it just garbage is garbage listen to
it listen to a two and a half hour
podcast about a subject so you can hear
people's actual knowledgeable and
thoughtful comments about it that to me
makes a lot more sense
yeah even on the four
minute deals where there's four five
people on there even if they don't
interrupt each other talk over each
other like one person can talk for what
I'm in it although it's weird out of
going you know I've done a decent amount
of television interviews and it's even
when you're in it it's even shorter than
it seems like you're watching it as you
know you have you just have to say
whatever it is you're gonna say just got
to say it in one maybe two maybe three
sentences yeah yeah and that's how they
get you to like if there's little if
it's like a sighted issue you know you
say the law and there's so many details
and nuance to it you know but man I
gotta get my mic or point across
meanwhile that's all this nuanced do you
think that the news companies are doing
that because people's attention spans
have gotten so short that they just
think well that's the best way we can do
this to just put on hey we put them on
there for four minutes if someone
doesn't like this subject or got someone
else coming on and you know in four
minutes later after the commercial break
yeah maybe I think it's a lot of time
has to do the show is just a certain but
I think I think that as one of their
gender I think they know attention spans
are short but I also think that
attention spans have been so coddled now
that people actually want the long
format that's why I think podcasts in
general yeah are doing really well
because people don't people want to get
engaged and listen to an actual opinion
yeah or or not even an opinion but facts
or yeah it's an opinion or facts I want
to listen to a full fault right also a
fully encompass fought about something
yeah not one-liners zinger hey I got you
yeah boring okay I can't watch it
anymore
yeah sometimes when you're watching
surfing sure you want to see you guys
read you know for a second or two or
whatever but sometimes you just want to
sit back and watch the lead that's true
I guess yeah all day well it is true
that you if you watch a surf movie of
the better surf movies they have you
know they show the guys in the morning
they're getting in the car you're kind
of with them right as opposed to just
boom it hit you yeah get the lip it the
lip it let get out if I don't get back
like those are those are cool you know
but what do you if you want to I and I
think a lot of people they want to sit
down they want to see these guys shaping
boards sure you know morning of the
earth are shaping boards they're watch
your shaping boards and then they're
going out and surfing the board that
they shaped in the morning they shape it
go out to go out surfer come back
adjust the fin make a little let's shave
the thin down that's that's pretty cool
to watch yeah critical to watch people
do 360s and 540's yeah it's cool but I
want something a little bit more
developed yeah that's actually the key
right there something develop do you
know you can't just like you can't watch
a shape someone doing the same shape for
a long time you wanna see the full
developed thought like how you put it
yes it was more sure there was that sure
yeah yes that show without a TV show now
is movie okay it was a movie then there
was a TV show got better buddy
there is no no sir yeah yeah uses
research a surf tank or whatever and
yeah there's only win Rick King goes to
North Shore Oahu why you know
learns to surf all over again
technically in a blaze the culture all
this stuff you know not as accurate as
maybe it could have been but a fun one
it's nonetheless a lot those cue that
one up I think my son watches that from
they get all the funny lines out of the
em and turtle dope I'll take your word
for the matter all right back to the
book in wielding the longsword oh this
is good and wielding along swords the
thumb and forefinger grip lightly the
middle finger grips neither tight mean
or loosely while the fourth and little
fingers grip tightly
there should be no slackness in the hand
the longsword should be taken up with
the thought that it is something for
killing opponents let there be no change
in your grip even when slashing
opponents make your grip such that your
hand does not flinch when you strike an
opponent's sword block it or pin it down
your thumb and forefinger alone should
change somewhat but in any case you
should grip your sword with the thought
of
killing your grip when cutting something
to test your blade and your grip when
slashing in combat should be no
different
gripping the sword as you would to kill
a man
generally speaking fixation and binding
are to be avoided in both the sword and
the hand fixation is the way to death
fluidity is the way to life this is
something that should be well understood
so not only you have normal face and
normal bearing your grips got to remain
the same no matter what you train how
you fight you're just maintaining the
same grip and then this idea of fixing
and binding and being stationary and
stagnant is the way to death and being
fluid and open in the mind and in the
way you present and the way you fight
that's the way to life the keelhauling
Tim Kennedy mentioned dry fire you know
kind of thing deal right so like you're
pulling the trigger the same way or
whether or not there's going to be you
know recoil in that way yeah anyway and
actually when you're shooting they'll do
this when they're training us to shoot
we'll they'll put a dummy around in our
magazine that is not and so then they
can see if you made some reaction
predicting or awaiting the kick of the
gun that's what throws your rounds off
so I put a dummy round in there and I'll
be watching you click click click click
boom boom boom boom boom and then click
you jerk your trigger and everyone knows
that you just made a mistake and they
can see it and that's hard yeah it is it
is good at that to be good at that one
oh now this is interesting he goes
through what he calls the five kinds of
guard and I looked at this guard is
basically the way you kind of position
yourself and he talks about the
different types of guard that there are
the first technique the the second the
third the fourth the fifth is the
different techniques and they're all
different positions that you hold the
sword and where you prepare for your
attack
and when he gets to the philosophical
part of it though on the teaching of
having a position without a position
having a position without a position or
a guard without a guard means that the
longsword is not supposed to be kept in
a fixed position nevertheless since
there are five ways of placing the sword
the guard positions must follow along
where you hold your sword depends on
your relationship to the opponent
depends on the place and must conform to
the situation wherever you hold it the
idea is to hold it so that it will be
easy to kill the opponent sometimes the
upper guard position is lowered a bit so
that it may becomes the middle position
while the middle guard position may be
elevated a bit depending on the
advantage thereof so that it becomes the
upper position at times the lower guard
position is also raised a bit to become
the middle position the two the
two-sided guard positions may be moved
somewhat toward the center depending on
where you are standing visa vie your
opponent resulting in either the middle
or the lower guard position in this way
the principle is to have a guard
position without a position first of all
when you take up the sword in any case
the idea is to kill the opponent even
though you may catch hit or block an
opponent slashing sword or tie it up or
obstruct it all of these moves are
opportunities for cutting down the
opponent so he's not trapped in this
rigid mindset that this is what I have
to do he's open-minded he's flexible now
here we go this must be understood if
you think of catching think of hitting
think of blocking think of tying up or
think of obstructing you will thereby
become unable to make the kill it is
crucial to think of everything as an
opportunity to kill this should be given
careful consideration
so they have here if you're thinking
defensively that's what you're thinking
about when you actually need to be
thinking about being offensive even when
you're defending you need to be thinking
about being offensive back to the book
in large-scale military science the
array of troops the raying of troops is
also a matter of positioning every
instance thereof is an opportunity to
win in war fixation is bad this should
be worked out federally striking down an
opponent in a single beat among the
rhythms used to strike an opponent there
is what is called a single beat finding
a position where you can reach the
opponent realizing when the opponent has
not yet determined what to do you strike
directly as fast as possible without
moving your body or fixing your
attention the stroke with which you
strike an opponent before he is thought
of whether to pull back parry or strike
is called a single deep so that's you
you can see that the opponent's not
quite prepared they're kind of
indecisive you can see it boom be
decisive make something happen to go for
the kill the rhythm of the second spring
the rhythm of the second spring is when
you're about to strike and the opponent
quickly pulls back or parries you feint
to blow and then strike the opponent as
he relaxes after tensing this is the
stroke of the second spring so again we
see these all the time and in jiu-jitsu
we see it in everything the sticky body
means getting inside and sticking fast
to an opponent when you get inside the
opponent's defenses you stick tight with
your head body and legs the average
person's the average person gets his
head and legs in quickly but the body
shrinks back sticking to an opponent
means that you stick so close that there
are no gaps between your bodies this
should be investigated carefully and
what's really interesting about this and
of course these are both two different
languages being translated but when the
Chechens fought the Russians in Chechnya
one of the things that the Chechens did
was they called this this
sticky they stuck to the Russians so the
Russians had air support the Russians
have artillery and the only way to
negate that or mitigate it for the
Chechens was to get so close to the
Russians that they couldn't use their
owner superior airpower and it's the
same thing with jiu-jitsu I mean
obviously a grappler is going to get
close so that they can avoid the strikes
of a striker yeah doesn't matter a stand
against many opponents discerning the
order in which opponents attack deal
with those who press forward first
keeping an eye on the whole picture
determining the stands from which
opponents launch their attack swinging
both swords at the same time without
mutual interference interference it is
wrong to wait prioritize and execute got
multiple people coming after you or
you're being a total attacked on
multiple fronts
each prioritize and execute advantage in
dueling means understanding how to win
using the longsword according to the
laws of martial arts this cannot be
written down in detail one must realize
how to win by practice study carefully
so again you're not going to get it just
by reading you're not going to get it
just by listening you got to do it
you've got to practice it synching
unhurried li understanding that it is
the duty of warriors to practice this
science determine that today you will
overcome yourself of the day before
tomorrow you will win over those of
lesser skill and later you'll win over
those of greater skill practice this is
something that requires thorough
examination with a thousand days of
practice for training and 10,000 days of
practice for refinement get it on
as far as my military science is
concerned I have discerned the
principles of living and dying through
numerous duels in which I set my life on
the line learning the science of the
sword getting to know the strengths and
weaknesses of opponents sword blows
comprehending the uses of blade and
ridge of the sword and practicing how to
kill opponents in the course of doing
this little sissy things never even
occurred to me especially when one is in
full combat gear one does not think of
small things I thought that might be
worth noting yes don't be thinking about
the little sissy things now he's talking
about here the physical situation
meaning what's going on in discerning
the lay of the physical situation there
is what is known as positioning yourself
with the Sun at your back this also
applies indoors so general ideas you
want to make sure that you put the Sun
behind you so that it's hard to see you
now what you have to be careful today
live real military scenarios you got to
be careful if you're not silhouetting
yourself so at nighttime you get on a
Ridgeline or you get light behind you
can be easier to you and what's the
bright blinding light and then it
becomes efficient so there's a big
difference between a bright blinding
light and silhouetting yourself so be
careful with that back to book in order
to look down on the enemy understand
that you should take your stand on the
highest ground even if it's only
slightly elevated take the high ground
or the high ground is going to take you
16:43 same same thing that I was
teaching in 2009 Kate diagram when you
get opponents to an obstacle in order to
prevent them from observing the
situation press your attack without
let-up so they cannot look around again
you get someone on the ropes kind of
back ya gotta get them you know what I'm
saying when they're on the ropes when
they're starting to fade a little bit
you're probably starting to fade a
little bit too right think about it if
you and I are in a grappling match or
we're going hard when I see you getting
tired
I'm probably
getting tired - mm-hmm not time for me
to rest just a lot of people they see
you get a little tired I say how cool I
can take a little breather now
yeah wrong answer less of my effort now
yeah wrong answer
it requires more effort yeah I'm going
to finish you off I'm gonna get the kill
when you want to attack you remain calm
and quiet then get the jump on your
opponent by attacking suddenly and
quickly you can preempt by being
outwardly powerful unswept while
inwardly leaving reserves you can also
get the jump by stealing your mind to
the utmost accelerating your pace a bit
and making a violent attack the instant
you get up close to the opponent in case
the opponent attacks swiftly you attack
calmly yet powerfully when the opponent
gets close tighten your bearing with
absolute resolve and when the opponent
shows signs of slacking overcome him
with force immediately then again when
an opponent attacks calmly and quietly
accelerate your own attacks lightly with
your body lightly buoyant when the
opponent gets close clash once and then
adapting to his condition overcome him
forcefully so this is what these are and
the what's important about these is that
understanding what's happening before
you enter the situation so let me give
you an example as you hear this all the
time in MMA there's certain MMA fighters
that come out of the gate blazing and
you hear all the time oh this guy he
knows he's got a weather the storm yeah
so that's exactly what oh you're gonna
attack me I'm gonna remain calm you're
going going all-out going crazy getting
nuts even this and what am i doing I'm
just going to remain calm just going to
take the hits I'm going to defend I'm
gonna let you and I'm going to do with
the resolve just going to be calm normal
face boom we're good and then you're
gonna wear yourself out then I'm gonna
attack you as opposed to if you come out
you're all nonchalant I might stop my
comment you hard to overcome you while
you're not mentally prepared for the
chaos and I'm going to bring to you yeah
in hopes that you can't
whether the storm right right whenever
opponents try and attack you let them go
ahead and do anything that is useless
while preventing them from doing
anything that is useful this is
essential to military science that
doesn't even need explanation except for
the fact that you see people all the
time that the enemies or the competitors
doing something that they don't like it
bothers them so they make effort to stop
it and there's a wasting their effort
yeah these actually be encouraging
people to waste their resources and time
yeah knowing the state of affairs in
large-scale military science knowing the
state of affairs means discerning the
flourishing and declining of opponents
discerning the intentions of adversary
troops and perceiving their condition
clearly seeing the state of affairs
determining how to deploy your own truth
so as to gain certain victory by the
principles of military science and doing
battle with the knowledge of what lies
ahead
also in individual martial arts you
determine your opponent's traditions
observe the personal character of
adversaries find out people's strengths
and weaknesses maneuvering ways contrary
to opponent's expectations determine the
opponent's highs and lows ascertain
rhythms in-between make the first move
this is essential so that's leadership
right there dealing with other people
know their character back to book if
your own power of insight is strong the
state of affairs of everything will be
visible to you once you have attained
complete independent mastery of martial
arts you'll be able to figure out the
minds of opponents and thus find many
ways to win this demands work
know what's happening you know I like
the fact that he's talking about
understanding your opponent's traditions
understanding their cultures what he's
talking about you got to understand what
your opponent's culture is and an
individual level and on a social level
all of it this integration is something
that happens to everything when a house
crumbles a person crumbles or an
adversary crumbles they fall apart by
getting out of rhythm with the times in
large-scale military science it is also
essential to find the rhythm of
opponents as they come apart and pursue
them so as to not let opening slip by if
you miss the timing of vulnerable
moments there is a likelihood of
counter-attack in individual martial
arts it also happens that an adversary
will get out of rhythm in combat and
start to fall apart if you let such a
chance get by you the adversary will
recover and forge you it is essential to
follow up firmly on any loss of poise on
the part of an opponent to prevent him
from recovering again you see this name
that may all-time get that guy on the
ropes get that guy dazed you got to get
on him finish him and you and I talked
tired people get in MMA you'll see
somebody really really rocked and losing
their bearings and the other guy won't
even be able to pursue him because he's
tired or overly cautious and then you
know what helps you get you get the guy
that goes nuts and gasses himself out
trying to finish a guy so hard and the
guy just hangs on ties them up or
whatever and then then also in the
disabled sir
yeah and that typically what that is
when they punch themself out that they
come when they get too excited like they
don't maintain the normal thing I'm not
a normal face yeah she's there and
there's and apparently you know I'm
listening to this and there is a
difference between normal face and then
being aggressive you know in attacks you
know like being offensive or whatever so
that's a more you can have normal face
while you're being aggressive that's
what everybody
the unaggressive doesn't mean you're
getting all you're losing your composure
rather aggressively attacking while
maintaining composure yeah for sure yeah
so a lot of times in MMA where you see a
guy you know boom you got the other guy
on the ropes and he maintains you can
you know guy getting too excited
you know he risks punching himself out
if he doesn't connect or if you you know
if the guy just doesn't worry
communicating occasionally guy gets just
super sloppy and gets yeah exactly right
because that is out of desperation or
you know he was seen that one who was I
think the guy's name is Scott who was it
Tim Lytle maybe what's it done anyway I
forget um so he gets hit in the liver I
think and it buckled him and he's you
can tell all the fights over for this
guy and the other guy comes running in
haymaker style you know like sloppy but
super aggressive and he sneaks one in as
the guys get knocked him out and it
looked like the fight was over for that
he lost his composure
yeah and maintain normal face no not at
all he was way too excited and he got
sloppy too got excited face yes exactly
back to the book becoming the opponent
means you should put yourself in an
opponent's place and think from the
opponent's point of view clearly letting
go for hands is when you and an opponent
are in a deadlock and no progress is
being made in the fight it means that
when you think you're going to get into
a deadlock you stop right away and seize
victory by taking advantage of a
different approach in large-scale
military science as well if there is
total deadlock and no progress is being
made there will be a loss of personnel
it is essential to stop right away and
seize victory by taking advantage of a
tactic unsuspected by the enemy in
individual martial arts also if you
think you are getting into a deadlock
then it is essential to immediately
change your approach ascertains the
opponent state and determine how to win
by means of a very different tactic this
is something you see a lot in the EUC
and everything in everything you see it
in war you see it in jiu-jitsu you see
the fighting you see it in business
people they get to a position
and there's some comfort there's some
level of comfort if you and I lock up
and you're my half guard and you're not
really going anywhere and I'm and I and
and I'm not going anywhere you're not
going anywhere there's a level of
comfort there yeah like why should I
take rescuing something else all right
and say we don't mind being dead lock
now what's important about this is he's
saying as soon as you sense it that's
got to be the hard part as soon as you
sense there's a deadlock that's when you
should make the change because the
longer I wait the longer the more
settled it becomes in the harder it is
to break out of that deadlock
if movement is so critical mental
physical movement is so critical that's
why when something go is going bad like
let's say you're in a public place and
something's going bad a terrorist comes
in and starts screaming shooting you
move immediately you get your instinct
you've got to be move immediately what
you don't want to do is freeze stop home
which is a very human instinct right
it's a very human instinct to freeze and
just take cover now there's shooting
going on depending on the kind of
shooting if there's heavy machine gun
fire but like that yes you have to get
to get down because it's bullets flying
all over the place if the bullets are
slowly going bop-bop-bop that means
someone's taking aim and shooting so if
you stay still you're gonna get shot if
you hear that steady pace you go you go
you zig zag you take cover you then you
bound to another position you move as
fast as you can yeah that quick movement
when you before the deadlock settles in
is when you want to do when someone's
about to in a in a situation like a
physical confrontation
don't let it get there make a move
before it gets there yeah which you know
hopefully means you leave you walk away
you know before the guy bow is up to you
and starts getting in your face you're
already gone didn't even let it get
there because now we're going to a
situation where it's we're gonna have to
make something happen yeah and that's
not good right it's not going to be good
sure oh I kicked it I kick this guy's
ass out in the street that's cool and
what's the other 14 alternatives you got
stabbed you got arrested
you got you broke his neck you're in
prison there's all kinds of bad ones
it's like one good out of four
team which is a I put the guy to sleep
and even that when we getting out of
that he bled on you yeah and we don't
know what kind of disease this guy has
yeah you know we we've talked about that
before but the bottom line is try and be
aware of when things are about to get
stagnant if you can change them then do
it then yeah it's all it ultimately
comes down to being ready yeah yeah yeah
and not necessarily ready for anything
specific it just you know one thing when
you get caught off guard psycho you got
your mind have to explore all these
options and all this time you know if
you this if you just been aware yeah
awareness goes so far like I did that
video on on real martial arts and and
you know I started off I said hey the
best form of self-defense is the gun but
if you and here because think about it
if you have somebody that truly is in a
high threat area you know you take a
woman or an older person that doesn't
have great physical strength and they're
in a high threat area to tell them that
you know learning jujitsu is going to be
the best thing for them is wrong right
the best thing for them is to in high
threat area is to have a weapon a a gun
that is the best thing to have that
truly will neutralize targets so but
that but what I didn't mention in that
video which I should have is yes the
first thing is mental awareness the
first thing is like oh yeah I'm aware of
what's happening I'm aware that I'm
going into a high threat area I'm gonna
go to another I'm gonna drive around
that area I see bad things going on on
my side the street I'm gonna walk across
the street and avoid it early enough
that I don't look like a victim because
if you see if if a perpetrator sees you
or a predator sees that you're avoiding
them then they think oh that's the
person scared does target for me yes
yeah they're weak that's why you got to
be aware so yes your honor press it
right and when you walk into a building
you walk into a public place you should
be looking around where the exits where
is their cover how fast can I get out of
here yeah that's what you should be
doing and and if you have that
predetermined that it's not even like it
takes that much effort you just have to
do it
you have to say oh I'm going into a high
school graduation and I'm gonna sit in
the spot where I'm close to the exit in
this case somebody goes crazy because
when is someone gonna go crazy we don't
know yeah but they do and so if you're
close to the exit you can get out of
there quickly or you can at least flank
the perpetrator and get rounds on them
before anything really bad happens yep
and you just compare that to the
alternative of not knowing right or you
know you go in you go oh this is a good
seat I'm able to see the graduation from
this middle spot that has no cover and
concealment anywhere around it and when
something goes sideways I'm going to be
one of the persons trapped in the mob
trying to get out of this two doors
while someone's shooting a machine gun
not good so be aware of your
surroundings is number one and then when
you see that thing happening act quickly
you know you see something shady going
on move towards that exit movement is so
key and being mentally prepared to make
the movement having that be a quick
reaction instead of a delayed reaction
and planning your situations that you're
in a spot where you can move quickly
it's critical in large-scale military
science when you cannot discern the
enemy state you pretend to make a
powerful attack and see what they do
that's pretty cool right I don't know
what the first person is not doing
anything I can't tell what they're gonna
do
make a little attack on them see how she
has to how they react to it and in
jiu-jitsu by the way it's gotta be a
real attack yeah you can't fake an
attack and you did to another person's
weak you have I mean like not trained
yeah nervous or so yeah you you need to
give them a real attack if I say oh I'm
gonna pretend to sweep echo so I can
expose his arm if I pretend to sweep you
you won't even defend it you don't have
to get to pretend you have to defend
against pretend eggs I've actually got
to try and sweep you that will expose
your arm because you have to defend the
sweep so your attacks I don't I don't
like to use the word pretend there
because if you're pretending well even
if you're even on the battlefield I'm
not gonna pretend to flank you I'm gonna
flank you yeah I'm gonna flank you and
if you don't defend it I'm gonna win if
you defend it cool now I can't you from
the other side yes feel like on the
movies
war movies right they they was it
because Rambo I don't know but you know
how they have the the girl you know
walks that's that's the the decoy so
obvious the girls that would be in a war
zone for sure right you gotta you got to
know that yeah watch out for that really
good-looking girl it look at that did
you know the battlefield yeah back to
look if you demonstrate strongly to
opponents oh this is good if you
demonstrate strongly to opponents how
you control the advantage they will
change their minds inhibited by this
strength so if I'm dominating you on the
jutsu mat and I'm just holding you
cross-eyed holding you across side
holding you across side I've given away
what I do to control you so now next
time you're not going to let me get
across side you're going to panic so or
you're going to knock on panic or you're
going to really defend that or this
harder and you're going to sacrifice the
cross line maybe you give up your back
because you realize a my back attacks
aren't as good and then now I'm not
getting where I want to be so if you
demonstrate you got to be careful you
can't be so dominant in what you're
doing that everyone sees it or that your
opponent Caesar that your competitor
sees what you're doing and then they can
counter it if you if you keep it
somewhat obscured by by you know smoke
and mirrors so that they can't tell
exactly how you're dominating that's a
positive thing that's one of the
drawbacks of having the same training
partner you know cuz you like I can
train a Greg so much and that we just
sit in this weird stalemated position so
much of the time too and it's almost
like it's subconscious at the end course
where you're not worried about certain
things now well this goes back what you
need to do within there is you need to
avoid that position before you get to it
yeah right as you get unique oh no we're
not going there yeah then back to the
book there is infection in everything
even sleepiness can be infectious and
yawning can be infectious
there's even infection of a time in
large-scale military science when
adversaries are excited and if evidently
are in a hurry to act you behave as
though you are
the unphased giving the appearance of
being thoroughly relaxed and at ease do
this and the adversaries themselves are
influenced by this mood becoming less
enthusiastic when you think your
opponents have caught that mood you
empty your own mind and act quickly and
firmly thus gaining the winning
advantage in martial arts as well it is
essential to be relaxed in body and mind
noticed a moment and opponent slackens
and quickly take the initiative to win
now the reason I wanted to point that
one out is it is for especially for you
know people in police officers bouncers
that's the de-escalation right someone's
getting all excited if you get excited
back at them and you're just escalating
the situation act calm calm men down
don't let them they want you to get
riled up like that drunk guy that makes
that that domestic violence situations
they want you may want to fight they
want to lash out if you give it to them
they're going to take it in a large in
large-scale military science it is
essential to cause upset it is critical
to attack resolutely where enemies are
not expecting it then while their minds
are unsettled use this to your advantage
to take the initiative and win there's
right in everything this means being
frightened by the unexpected in
individual martial arts you can threaten
by means of your body you can threaten
by means of your sword you can threat by
means of your force what is essential is
to suddenly make a move totally
unexpected by the opponent pick up on
the advantage of the fright and seize
victory right then and there this must
be worked out thoroughly this is
whenever I catch deed whenever I catch
Dean I catch him only by surprise like I
kick if he knows what I'm doing he stops
the only times I catch him is by
surprise and any you know he'll say oh
man I did not expect an armlock there
for a while ago you know I was c'mere
c'mere c'mere clear cracker and he gets
so good at defending c'mere I wasn't
hitting it in one day boom threw in our
market I did that to you a couple
right you were you said the exact same
thing yeah dude let's defend in the heck
out that Chimaera and then BOOM yeah
straight arm lock yeah that's and what
got you is just surprised surprised
because your defense is solid on what
you see mMmmm it's those things that you
don't see yeah that which you cannot
defend and let's yeah I mean like
especially when you get advanced that is
the whole of jujitsu right there
yeah say no that's the provo like
there's times were Dean I know exactly
what he's going to do and he's doing it
with such methodical perfection that I
did not stop it
yeah and that is so bothered hold event
even that kind of is totally splitting
hairs but even that in a way he might
have little micro surprises you know
that established the position yes
getting to the position he definitely
does that yeah but once he's in a
position and I know AJ matter fact
they'll be telling me they'll be telling
me well you know what's coming to me I
wish you could stop this it's actually
sad that you can if we talking so much
smack to me which obviously is even more
frustrating but that's because he's
better than me education surprised me
he's just got the skills yeah and he
knows he does know he knows how to do
those movements with such authority and
precision that you're just you're just
in trouble yeah you know he does this
one should be called it like the
arresting officer the he'll start
talking me like he says like he's a cop
and he'll be going insane sir just calm
down just calm down sir and he's got me
face down like I'm getting arrested
sitting and he does that weird career
week and he's you know he just he says
he'll say look at the wall over there
and I'm trying not to look where you who
like force my face yeah it's it's
humiliating
that's why when either one of us are
we're at a point in the digits or now
where if either one of us get in our
dominant position yeah the other person
we are going to make them suffer
immensely and he's got more dominant you
know if I get a cross-eyed on him he's
in trouble and if I get him on all fours
he's in trouble he I'm gonna make him
suffer in both those positions straight
up I might not submit him but he's gonna
suffer and he's got those two positions
the same thing like if he's a crossed
out of me or he's a farm on all fours
he'll make me suffer but also he has the
mount if he mounts me I suffer
yeah but brutally because I'm looking at
him which is even more horrible you know
that he will literally drip sweat into
my eyes purposely yeah yeah you know if
he's in the mount he'll sit there and
aim sweat drop coming off his nose and
hit me in the eye said that and tell me
you know Chinese water torture like as
soon as your mom is a Chinese water if
he's sweating if we're already warmed
Chinese water torture and I've seen Dean
communicate all obviously I was it da
I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you enjoy this and when I
get him that's what makes the jujitsu so
fun the game within the game yeah back
to the book flustering opponents means
acting in such a way as to prevent them
from having a steady mind in large-scale
or in large-scale military science this
means that you assess adversaries minds
on the battlefield and use the power of
your knowledge of the art of war to
manipulate their attention making them
think confusing thoughts about what
you're going to do it means finding a
rhythm that will flush your adversaries
accurately discerning where you can win
in individual martial arts as well
you try various maneuvers according to
the opportunity of the moment making the
opponent think you are now going to do
this now that now something else until
you find the opponent starting to get
flustered and thus you win at will
this is the essence of battle it should
be studied carefully so clearly making
fluster in your opponent on the
battlefield in business wherever you are
in conversations you're trying to get
someone sauce from France from obviously
in jiu-jitsu if you start getting
flustered you're doing this in the
context of large-scale combat mixing
means that when two groups are facing
off and your opponents are strong you
attack one of the opponent's flanks as
if to mix with them then when you see
the opponent's crumble you leave off an
attack again where they are strong
flanking always mountain and sea means
that is bad to do the same thing over
and over again you may have to repeat
something once but it should not be done
a third time when you try something on
an opponent if it does not work the
first time you will not get any benefit
out of rushing to do it again change
your tactics abruptly doing something
completely different if that still does
not work then try something else
thus the science of martial arts
involves the presence of mind to act and
see where the enemy is like a mountain
and act as a mountain when the enemy is
like a sea this requires careful
reflection so what's interesting about
this is you actually there is a benefit
if you in jujitsu and on the battlefield
if you try something and you see the
reaction now you know the reaction and
you try it again if you automatically
counter the reaction that's a great
setup so Dean will do three three times
he'll do something three times he'll go
once fake once fake if he doesn't do the
third time he won't do it which is a
great rule to have because now that
person has thought oh they're setting
this up but yeah so sometimes it's good
to try something you see the defenses
and now you can attack it with those
defenses understood it is beneficial
so would you judge it that it's so
complex you can go for a guillotine but
the way you went for the guillotine can
change a lot to you know like some
I won't try it from this very exact
position you know two three times I'll
go on didn't work maybe I'll try it
again all obviously didn't work you good
at defending from there there maybe
you'll do something else something on
something else and then come back to it
you know those guys yeah you've got it
you got it you that's a great point if I
try a guillotine on you and then I try
it again
you already know it's like if I try one
on you it's tight close but you get out
you're defending it like crazy now
you're not even let me get it again yeah
I got to attack 14 I got to attack up
multiple other things probably like
probably around five or six other things
yeah before I come back to the
guillotine and I'm going to get it deep
right then I got good defense right on
my van throw a little extra yeah you're
gonna set it up different typically you
know you know those guys are really good
at triangles yeah I'll just fly Motta
anywhere yeah so all that is is it's the
same thing where they'll go for a
triangle and sure you can even be like
yeah I know this could a triangle so I'm
going to defend the triangle so you know
how to defend this right so you're not
as good so you're used to defending the
triangle from from the guard that's it
meanwhile this guy's doing some half
guard thing to sweep you here Glen you
base too sweet he's going for that
triangle you know so he knows it from
everywhere so it's the same
eventualities but the way he approaches
difference so it's like attacking this
mountain we're not going to go up this
straight in the front of the mountain
we're going to try the front ok defended
we're going to try it from the side okay
defended we're going to try from the
side here then go to the front and go to
the other side you know an airborne yeah
yeah whatever
back to the book when fighting with
enemies if you get the if you get to
feelin stalled up and are making no
progress you toss it will toss your mood
away and think in your heart that you
are starting everything anew as you get
the rhythm you discern how to win this
is becoming a new anytime you feel
tension and friction building up between
yourself and others if you change your
mind that very moment you can prevail by
the advantage of radical difference this
is becoming new so sometimes you guys
got to put your attitude in check right
uh reason that I thought about that I
thought about that in terms of from
leadership perspective dealing with
people the minute you know he
an iron a meeting and almost when I
start feeling that friction I'm I should
need to recognize I'm doing something
wrong I'm creating friction I'm not
making progress need to start anew
need to take a different approach you
need to realize that early when you're
dealing with other human beings the more
I continue down the bat approach that
wasn't working the harder it is to back
out of so you start sensing that bad
approach go a different direction when
you are fighting adversaries and get to
feeling stalled up in petty maneuvers
remember this rules military science
while in the midst of the minutiae
suddenly you shift to a large
perspective changing to great or small
is an intentional part of the science of
the art of war it is essential for
warriors to seek this even in the
ordinary consciousness of human life
this mentality is critical to military
science whether large or small scale
this concern should be given careful
consideration so this is detachment you
have to detach you can't get caught in
the minutiae and you also can't get
caught in the large scale you have to be
able to see both of them and when you
when you feel like you've spent too much
time in one time to back out and see the
other one when you start and when you
start feeling bogged down step back step
back
take the large perspective let me ask
you this a gear obviously well-versed in
the in a lot of like detachment for
example do you conduct like your
everyday life just that just you have a
forefront of your mind you're just yeah
I mean I'm not saying you're detached
all the time but you you know like
you'll detach it just a split second
when you have to anything is it that
available no actually I'm more often I'm
observing myself the whole time okay
yeah now this is weird because sometimes
people say no you enjoy your life and
that's not true you come to jujitsu with
me I I will smile oh I'm having fun
right I'm I'm actually so detached doing
jujitsu but I'm in the like the Zen
mindset right my mind is not even there
so that's that's very pleasurable for
but you know I'm not like detached when
I'm when I'm playing with my
year-old daughter I'm not attached when
I'm you know hanging out with my family
not in this big detachment mode but if
I'm dealing with one of my kids and one
of my kids did something I shouldn't
have done or I'm gonna catch then yes
absolutely yeah absolutely when I'm
dealing with a client and you know
they're having issues with something I'm
detached you know a client starts
getting mad at another client and I'm
there I'm detached you know that's one
of the benefits of a vessel on front is
actually on front when we come into work
with a company we're but we're de facto
detached and they're always caught up in
these crazy situations these companies
well not all of them but even a company
that's doing well they've got things
that they don't see because they're in
the fight they're there they're in the
tactical battlefield they're getting
after it
they got sales they got to do they got
numbers they got to reach they got all
these things going on they got goals
they got raises that they're doing it
got all those things happening and
they're in it so when we come in we
aren't attached it's just inherent in
what we're doing and it's very
beneficial because we're detached from a
leadership perspective and that's what
we're looking at so some companies might
come in and they're detach but they're
not there to look at the leadership
they're look at the finances right there
look there to look at the process you
know a lot of companies need help with
their process and that's cool there's
companies that there's consulting
companies that come in looking process
there's consulting companies that come
in and look at finance we're consulting
company that comes in and looks at
leadership and what we have is we've
been doing it for so long not just in
the military in the military in the
business world that when we come in
detached we carry out this role it for
us to what's happening because we just
we've seen it before yeah we've seen it
before you know and then oh but in those
cases you know when the session when
you're quote/unquote at work you know or
imagine it's easy to just be empty
tattoo yeah but like what I'm saying is
just your everyday life you know you
talked about like with your kids or
something like that is it is it easy to
detach at a moment's notice or is it the
kind of okay I think I got a DITA I
think I'm conditioned yeah the point
that when things start to escalate I
automatically detach yeah yeah like when
I see something you know if I see
say a lifeguard situation you know I'm
down at the beach or I'm down at the
ocean and I see a lifeguard situation
something happening yeah I instantly
detach and I'm looking around I'm seeing
where the where positions aren't seeing
what we can do to help I'm instantly
detached whereas a lot of people are not
detached at all oh my god is right
instantly detached completely yeah
that's the kind of system or even you
know if if there's an escalation in the
household of some kind raised voices or
whatever which is not honestly there's
not a lot my house but if there is it's
an instant attachment for me is an
instant right here my kid yelling you
know maybe raising his voice to my wife
it's instantly it's not it's not why is
that kid your notes it okay boom I'm
detached I'm going to find what's going
on yeah that's very I think I've
conditioned myself you have to be like
that and I think that's why I always
talk about you got to have those red
flags right identify what it is that you
do as a human that make that makes you
realize you're escalating to yeah that's
what you got to watch out for yeah
it really seems like that's like the
goal you know to make it to have it be
just like how you have in addition yeah
to have it conditioned into your brain
that when you when things are escalating
around you it's a warning that flashes
you just go back at automatic room that
that's what's not good like you know
we'll be walking down the street it'll
be some kind of a situation in the
streets instant attach it instant all
right what's going on where's the cops
where's the cars what you know it's it's
that's all the time yeah because really
the the default I think for you know
your average person is how it's not like
okay what's the scenario what's the
problem to be solved how do I solve it
it's more how do I feel about this you
know now that we're thinking about it I
bet so I was when I was training I was I
spent time in the training Department of
SEAL team one training cell when I was
part of cadre hell yeah and and there
and then obviously I ran the training
for the West Coast SEALs when I was at
trade debt and in both what is this may
have really helped me cuz in both those
situations I was an instructor so
therefore while we would throw
hard problems at people I would be once
again de facto I am detached because I'm
not in the platoon that's going through
the training so I am detached and so I
always got to see how much more you can
see when you are guests so as I learn
that over the years and saw over and
over again that I could even when I was
a young seal in in cadre at SEAL team
one we would
I'm sitting there as an e5 seal you know
an enlisted seal not in charge of
anything but I'm watching the the
situation unfold and I can see what the
solution is man and and the end of and
the platoon chief can't see it and he's
more experienced than I am he can't see
it cuz he's in it and so I would always
just say well I'm just all I need to do
is just step back see what I used to be
able to see when I was an instructor
easy boom yeah I probably got to train
my attachment by actually not being in
participating but watching me like if
you sat around and watched street fights
off like as a bouncer he is a bouncer
you're sober you're seeing it day in day
out eventually as them longer but when
you first became a bouncer there was a
fight where you detached at all no he
probably weren't you're probably oh
there's like America and then the more
experience you got the more level-headed
you got you can always tell a good
bouncer when they yeah hey you know they
can come in they can take a total not
get they're not escalating themselves
they're detached so you probably achieve
some of that as well yes fully yeah so
you've it's almost like you you
recognize just over and over again where
the advent or the beneficial position is
and it's outside not in sight as far as
mentally and outside your own head not
inside your own head yeah that's
goodness the goal right there it is
class men yeah back to the book military
science involves knowledge of the
methods of other schools unless you know
the ways of other schools you certainly
cannot understand the way of my
individual school God understand your
end we got understand other methods got
understand the way other people are
doing things there are some other
schools
that are fond of extra long swords from
the point of martial art I see them as
weak schools at times when you are
engaged in an opponent at close quarters
the longer sword the longer your sword
is the harder it is to strike with it
you cannot swing the sword back and
forth enough and it becomes a burden
then you are in a worse situation than
someone wielding a small sidearm sword
in the context of large military science
the extra-long sword is the large
contingent a shorter one is a small
contingent is a battle between a small
contingent and a large contingent
impossible there are many examples of a
small contingent winning over a large
contingent thus in my individual school
there is a version there is an aversion
to narrow biased attitude
this calls for careful examination so
yes or just like with a longer sword the
harder it is to maneuver with a smaller
sword it's easier to maneuver if you
take a big giant element with you on the
battlefield it's harder to maneuver if
you take a smaller in the business world
you set up your company this large
business it's going to be less
maneuverable if you break it into
smaller teams that are more maneuverable
could be very beneficial so you should
have an aversion towards biased
attitudes that book if you slash with
unreasonable force when you are going to
kill someone
intending to deal a powerful blow of the
sword you will not be successful even
when you are making a test cut on a
dummy or something it is wrong to try to
deliberately slash powerfully when
facing an enemy in mortal combat nobody
thinks of striking weekly or powerfully
when one thinks of killing each other
when one only thinks of killing the
other there's no sense of strength and
of course no sense of weakness one only
thinks of the death of the enemy and I
like that because obviously we see this
in in martial arts when somebody's
trying to knock the opponent out with
every swing that they take and they miss
all of them yeah they're winding up in
there
graphing it just doesn't work the way
you knock someone else bus you know
keeping your tight combos together and
throwing them and in the business world
what I see is when people try and lead
again this is so strange
but leaders supposed to be powerful
right yeah and sometimes people lead
with too much power yeah and and they
lead with so much force that they're
that they're missing what's happening
they're missing the the the nuances of
the people that they're leading and
they're taking away the power from the
people that they're trying to lead yeah
is it like Kyle like they might be
focusing too much on being powerful yeah
they might be focusing too much on being
powerful they might be focusing on too
much on being the leader right and then
we get all ends of the spectrum here
some people aren't leading enough right
buzzer that's horrible some people are
leading too much which means they're
turning into a micromanager or they're
overbearing and they're not getting
feedback from people so with both those
if you're trying to lead so hard another
thing that happens you see people try
and do is that they're chasing the
target which is something we say from
shooting where they're basically
shooting where their last round went
well you see people that are leadership
positions they're trying so hard to be
the leader they want they get feedback
and they adjust and they get feedback
again they adjust again they're trying
so hard to do a good job that they're
actually failing they're actually
failing because they're trying too hard
to make people happy they're trying too
hard to adapt to what people are the
feedback that they're getting and like
what are your principles okay
the principles of your leadership
shouldn't change then the principles of
the goals that you're trying to
accomplish they shouldn't be changing
day to day so why would your little
tactics be strange changing day to day
now you're moving all over the place so
sometimes people lead too hard hmm got
to be careful that one careful
consideration yes if this should be
examined carefully in the course of
struggle for victory by military science
you win by disrupting others defenses by
making moves' opponents do not expect by
confusing opponents or irritating them
or scaring them sensing the pattern of
the rhythm when the ponents get mixed up
to see victory
clear distraction the focus of the eyes
depends on the school
there are those who fix their eyes on
the opponent sorts and there are those
who fix their opponents fix their eyes
on the opponent's hands
there are those who fix their eyes on
the opponent's face and there are those
who fix their eyes on the opponent's
feet and so on when you try to fix your
eyes on some particular point there is a
sense of distraction and this becomes
what is known as an affliction in
martial arts generally speaking the
focus of the eyes in martial arts is on
the hearts and minds of the people
involved we need to understand people we
need to understand human nature and lead
and to fight and to win in my martial
art there's no change in footwork it is
just like walking along a road as usual
following the rhythm of the opponent
finding the right physical position in
conditions of both hurry and calm the
stride should be orderly without slack
or excess this is what when I was a
brand new seal and one of my favourite
awesome instructors that was putting I
was one of the cadre when I was going
through but he's the first guy that I
heard that running to your death but
when he would move he was an extremely
is probably one of the best shooters in
the SEAL Teams as far as pistol rifle
combat shooting he was definitely one of
the best and when he would move through
a building he would just be moving at
this steady pace and it was just the
most awesome thing it's faster than a
walk but it's definitely not a run and
it's smooth and he would give us little
examples of how effective it was and how
you needed to move that way and that's
that's that's exactly what this reminded
me of like a good pace solid pace and
you just steady hmm back to the book
when you master an art or science you
performance does not appear to be fast
the performance of an expert seems
relaxed but does not leave any gaps the
actions of trained people do not seem
rushed the jeff glover when you're
watching him no word that always comes
to my mind is smooth yeah
and he's going fast about it but it
looks so smooth yeah and it is fast
lightning fast but so smooth yeah my way
of teaching martial arts is to have
beginners learn and practice those
techniques that are easily mastered
first teaching them the principles that
they will readily understand as for
those things that their minds have a
hard time reaching I observe the
understanding of the individual
subsequently teaching them deeper
principles gradually step by step so you
start teaching people things that they
understand accordingly in transmitting
my science I do not care for written
pledges or articles of penalties
observing the intellectual power of
students teaching them a straight path
having them abandon the bad aspects of
the five ways or the six ways of martial
arts so that they naturally enter in to
the real science of warriors causing
their minds to be free from doubt this
is the way I teach martial arts thorough
training and practicing necessary so
this reminds me of all the clickbait
articles that are out there that say in
fact we made a funny video that said the
one thing you need to do to chase and it
was right it could fade because you see
those all times I was looking at a
website the other day or a social media
feed the other day from of those
websites every I count like 14 in a row
of the RL that were posted or five
things that every CEO does yeah
seven steps to you know this and four
because those are just quick pay people
like uncle that's cool I broken it down
into four things I can easily understand
out click I'm gonna click on that let's
do it and now I can be now I can achieve
you know whatever so they need to know I
don't have to work and you don't have to
work and just you know more
the list value good you know so that's
some stuff you gotta watch out for click
on those things but you know what that's
what people do
they're interested set in ways a Navy
SEAL
blah blah blah they did that they've
done that with some of mine they took
they took the dichotomy of leadership
and they made it into an articles like
12 things every leader Navy SEALs 12
things every leader needs to
characteristics or somebody broke it
down like that they've done that with
actually quite a few things yet we've
done they've they've changed it from you
know the dichotomy of leadership which
is a concept right it's a concept and
there are some examples of the concept
but that's the one that they turned into
like a cartoon where they got me in all
these weird different outfits can you
see that there's epic got me is like a
salmon colored sports jacket and they
got me on one of them is a dumb dressed
like Sherlock Holmes I'm serious this
exists wait is the video Miller or like
that's it's a it's a cartoon I guess is
what I call but it's an article okay it
is this insider it's an article it's got
these cartoons of me and it's saying the
12 I think it's the 12 characteristics
every leader needs to follow but they
took the dichotomy of leadership which
is a concept of which I give examples in
the book of how this concept applies but
they said no not a concept you get a 12
you we don't want a concept that might
be too hard to understand right we're
gonna cut on that yeah gotta click on
those yeah well in their defense it is
more like what he call it digestible
forget it for sure no I I totally
understand what they're doing and you
know what if it gets someone which is
their goals to get people to read it and
if someone reads it goes okay that's a
cool I understand there's a constant be
honest yeah credit good job they are but
but what we see is people that are doing
it and they're actually their purpose is
to get to click and they're not actually
trying to introduce people to something
more deep than that there's something
deeper than that they're just trying to
get them to click on that and and feel
good for the next 30 seconds like oh man
I'm going to definitely do those four
steps three things to do to incinerate
belly fat
yeah there's a go on there you go
there's another one
incineration I like it very powerful
back to the book in my individual school
there is no such thing as a distinction
between initiatory and inner lore about
the long sword so that is awesome and
what he's saying is there's no
difference between what you learn in the
beginning and what you learn in the end
it's the same I was talking about that
with lace today the concepts are the
concepts the concepts of the concepts
and what you learn in the beginning
about combat they stay true and that's
why we're reading a book from 1643
that's telling you to take the high
ground yeah that's why because what you
get introduced to the true concepts they
remain constant do the tactics change
sure do we get radio so we get night
vision and we get long-range weapons yes
of course we get all those things but
the principles the fundamental
principles of combat leadership they
don't change
there is dr. Booker there is no such
thing as the ultimate guard it is only a
matter of understanding its effective
qualities in your heart and mind this is
what is essential to martial art so I
think it's so important and I've always
tried to maintain this is that there is
no perfect thing there is no perfect
thing enough I've said this about
jiu-jitsu I mean I always get
pigeonholed as a jujitsu like Oh Jocko
thinks this is the best thing in the
world yeah when I will readily and have
always readily admitted the many
weaknesses of jiu-jitsu I happen to love
gdq as a thing to do as a hobby and I
also do think it is the best place to
start your self-defense journey but then
you absolutely have to learn how to
wrestle you absolutely have to learn how
to box you absolutely have to learn some
more Thai and beyond that you have to
start learning weapons you have to learn
how to share all those things are
important
and with jiu-jitsu same thing even
inside of jiu-jitsu I don't look at him
say there's a one way to do it the
minute you say there's a one way in play
you're you're getting flanked you're
getting flanked back to the book this is
now we're getting the last scroller the
scroll of emptiness Warriors learn
military science accurately and go on to
practice the techniques of martial arts
diligently the way that is practiced by
warriors is not obscure in the least
without any confusion in mind without
slacking off at any time polishing the
mind and attention sharpening the eye
that observes and the eye that sees one
should know real emptiness as the state
where there is no obscurity and the
clouds of confusion have cleared away so
we need here like that talking about the
empty mind and all that really good
definition of what that is
no obscurity and the clouds of confusion
have gone away what they call that the
mooch in mind you should I don't know
they say there's a word like I put a
deal with this right now I call monkey
mind actually it's what I've always
called it just back to book knowing that
mentality taking straightforwardness as
basic taking the real mind as the way
practicing martial arts in the broadest
sense thinking correctly clearly and
comprehensively taking emptiness as the
way you see the way as emptiness
emptiness there is good but no evil
wisdom exists logic exists the way
exists mind is empty 12 May 1645 and
that's how he wraps it up and about a
month later and about a week before he
died which is on the 13th of June 1645
he wrote his final piece which is called
a decoder which translates to the path
of alumnus or the way to go forth alone
or the way of walking alone or the way
to be followed alone I found all those
different translations and all those
titles one thing that comes through
clearly is that this is a piece about
asceticism which is a great word then
you hear a lot in in religious
philosophies and it means severe
self-discipline and avoidance of all
forms of indulgence that's that's what
the zetas sysm is and so here he's got
these 21 rules these 21 rules to walk
this path of the lowness then we're
gonna go through one except everything
just the way it is
that's pretty simple and it's pretty
damn powerful to do not seek pleasure
for its own sake 3 do not under any
circumstances depend on a partial
feeling for think lightly of yourself
and deeply of the world that's called
humility 5 be detached from desire your
whole life long and that's hard to do
and there's one of my if I had to pick a
favorite poet besides Shakespeare but
there's another guy named William Blake
who is the poet and he was a painter and
he he printed things and he was a I
studied them College didn't like a lot
of stuff I said in college but I liked
William Blake and one of the things that
when I read that line I thought about
something that William Blake had said
and this is a totally contrary to that
lesson this those who restrain desire do
so because theirs is weak enough to be
restrained I'm not even going to take a
side on that one I'm gonna let you
Shashi and William Blake figure that one
out I think you can't balance those two
I guess I just took aside then oh I
didn't love it right in the red in the
middle the balance I'm about the balance
six do not regret what you have done
seven never be jealous
boom by the way eight never let yourself
be saddened by a separation nine
resentment and complaint are appropriate
neither for oneself or others we don't
like plates around here
10 do not let yourself be guided by the
feeling of lust or love now people could
obey that one especially between the
ages of 16 and 25 if you solve all kinds
of problems yourself in your life
11 in all things have no preferences
think about that think about that think
about if everything that you deal with
on a day to day basis you you try and
not have preferences 12 be indifferent
to where you live that's tough one for
me
kind of like San Diego yeah do not
pursue the taste of good food kind of a
challenging one
it may be pretty maybe he wasn't yeah
he's around rib eyes but he was around
sushi though so let's guess you noticed
something might be but I'll tell you
what the fasting thing is I've been like
just getting after some fast lately it's
real so good yeah it feels so good and
somebody asked me on Twitter the other
day do you ever not scratch an itch just
to work on your this one other nails
like yeah who doesn't do that right but
there is something cool about the
fasting the control the discipline is
put is pretty cool yeah it's it's pretty
cool too and it feels rewarding yeah it
feels rewarding every time you say I
don't really need to eat that whatever
that 10 years yeah look like I'm not
gonna die yeah I can make it too you
know this evening what I'm gonna eat a
nice big dinner mm-hmm there's something
good about there's something rewarding
yep yeah in a couple of ways for sure
that each thing I've done that before
like actually a lot of times just to see
not because one more yourself I can be
would not scratch of age but just to see
like what could happen to the itch you
know you usually get scratched and
that's it like what's gonna happen
though if I just let it go maybe your
arm will grow with ya they're infected
yeah but I found this is two different
things one thing that happens is it
simply goes away it goes away then the
other or ultimately they both go away
but the other one is like a it gets
crazy
to the point where you get like a hum is
a a mosquito bite or that's a little
different yeah but still it's an itch
though sure the itch just gets like
deeper and it's crazy but it goes away
yeah discipline discipline fourteenth do
not hold on to possessions you no longer
need again the original minimalist here
yeah I need to get minimalist with
something like two old t-shirts it's
make way for the other half of old
geezer and I got old jujitsu t-shirts
from 1997 competition I want to throw
that away your little fundamental
meaning I want that thing I just give
you that new one no let's not get rid of
now this is an interesting one number 15
do not act following customary beliefs
so here's a guy you know from the
samurai tradition steeped in tradition
he's like don't act but as customary
beliefs yeah have it open mind yeah do
not collect weapons or practice weapons
beyond what is useful well some of us
like weapons yes do not fear death
number 17 do not fear death that's
affirmative
number 18 do not seek to possess either
goods or Fife's beyond your old age or
four year old age make sense right
nineteen respect Buddha and the gods
without counting on their help without
counting on their help
seems like a good move number 20 you may
abandon your own body but you must
preserve your honor indeed and number 21
never stray from the way and that's some
incredible guidance and so much of it is
so simple and yet so powerful and it's
from 1645 and what struck me the most
about this these 21 rules is that he
wrote them on his deathbed and the
suspicions he died of some kind of
cancer which had rapidly weakened him
and this is what he wrote on his
deathbed you will know not he wrote
about not letting desires control you
but controlling your desires
you will not about gaining more
possessions but ridding yourself of them
you are not being the center of the
world but being humble being in the
world and he wrote as a warrior not
about fighting things but accepting them
and he wrote about controlling his
feelings
and all those rules what they're about
is they're about discipline discipline
and in his final days after this
incredible life that he lived he knew it
was discipline that would set him free
from those clouds of confusion and I
think we should probably all pay
attention to that and I think that's all
we've got
from musashi for tonight until we get to
episode 100 will will be covering the
novel
musashi which I was reading it the other
night and there's a reason why we're
going to cover it I think it's the first
novel we're going to cover mm-hmm
in fact it is there's no one getting
covered any novels the way the warrior
kids in office yeah but this is the
first novel will come now everyone
thought myself included that the first
novel we would cover would be blood
meridian which is also historically
based novel I'm still not ready for
blood meridian and I'm still not ready
for blood meridian I'm reading it over
and over again little chunks of it and
it's deep and it's so the first novel
will be Musashi
and we're gonna learn a lot from that
one and I'm gonna start with the same
opening we started with today sure that
opening that opening is just legit isn't
it it is when you read that opening the
whole world's gone crazy the man one
might as well be a dead leaf floating in
the autumn breeze he's laying piles of
corpses that's how you kick off a novel
we can learn a lot we can always learn a
lot from the past and you know speaking
of learning Craig's sure is there
anything that you could teach us quickly
under doubt if anyone wants to learn how
to support this podcast yeah of course
when you say quickly you want me to just
talk in a fast pace or keep it short or
both take a little bit of both I'm not
trying to truncate it you know your gig
you know you don't want me to rush per
se I don't want you to rush but I don't
want to be here much longer Lily daddy
for yes I got alright well let's talk
about on it I feel that's the best way
to start Oh until Hawaii yeah story
that's right what's why I went to Kauai
forgot my curl rough deal swarm over
there so not too bad and a lot of the
workouts I was doing we're pretty like
light so it was less than a factor but
when I came home next day I walked down
just strangely because in Hawai you do a
lot of you know walking on the beach all
this stuff I'm dragging my kids around
in this wagon so it's weird your feet
get it worked out so I'm walking down
the stairs today oh my feet are all
stiff anyway no krill oil boom back on
the krill oil back home all good so
point there being don't stop taking your
krill oil you will feel it look it's not
a detrimental thing well for me it's not
on I can't speak for everybody it could
be detrimental if you stop but you know
like your joints being stiff Oliver I
think essentially might affect other
people while another feet
yeah yeah my keys for sure Oh krill oil
is for your joints I get mine it on it
chocolate his gets is it on it on it is
the most reputable place to hit it
omega-3s for your joints also what else
do we need to get after it if you're
going high intensive Roux going
high-performance for yourself I'm not
saying Olympic athlete necessarily I've
not seen not Olympic athletes
necessarily shroom tech sport you know
keeps you in the yellow and the green it
says it doesn't allow you to go in the
red that's how it feels that's my best
way to sum it up like if you have
another round let's say you're on your
last set of like I don't know jiu-jitsu
or something hard or you're doing
circuit training you got to do one more
round this one will get you there
without going into the red it's called
shrimp export do it lets you utilize
your oxygen consumption into your
muscles better and more efficiently so
we're better also you know good way to
do that is when you breathe with your
diaphragm from what I read you uptake
10% more oxygen hmm remember that next
to me breathing from bemidji breathe
British also you know breathing excess I
thought breathing exercises were like
all these Yogi's they're just doing
breathing exercises you know like I know
how to breathe he was breathing when I
was born and I know how to breathe
thirtysomething some odd years of
breathing experience I know but those I
can experience breezes are very
experienced reins and holding my breath
all that stuff you know where you're
from Hawaii hey man you know you could
have jump in the water every once in a
while
swim underneath it anyway when you
breathe those muscles but you know I
mean that'd help you breathe in your
ribs and your diaphragm like if those
are strong you can breathe better true
I'm just saying that don't neglect that
so the breathing exercise people respect
but chemically if you want you know
better oxygen uptake true to export
that's the one krill oil alpha brain for
your brain I can't go into the
neuroscience of it right now but you can
if you want just go to the website on a
comp and if you want 10% off of any of
this stuff
go on it calm / Yakko now don't think
that alpha brain shrooms export in crude
oil are the only things on there because
there's I'm tempted to say literally I
don't really overuse the word literally
don't know you don't ya approved you
said yeah so I'm gonna say borderline
literally there's stuff or anything on
there like if you need supplementation
for something they've even workout
equipment on there like good stuff too
yeah I don't think you'll find like a
like dumbbells though no there's no
because that's not real you can get
Dumbo's anywhere yes going to Amazon for
dumbbells and speaking of Amazon
actually just so I'm clear though if you
want 10% off this stuff there is there
is a lot of cool stuff they even have
normal like workout stuff but the cooler
version of it like how I always
mentioned the kettlebells kettlebells
are cool in and of themselves and beyond
the coolness there they're one of the
best exercise equipment equipment
pictures of occurrences of equipment
exactly right mid-foot but I did um it's
called clean and press right creeping
kettlebells yes yes man your legs and
it's a jerk
alright yeah after split okay so boom
clean press and then boom right to
burpees so I go six and five six and
five metcon just go eight minutes
Oh many as you can I I wasn't focusing
on as many as I can I was trying to go
for like seven set oh I lost count of
the set so the first time I was doing it
my son he's nine months old by the way
it's crawling around I can't be flying
the kettlebells and landing on his
anything no yeah no you don't wanna be
anywhere they come every weekend exactly
right so I lost nonetheless the point is
I lost count when I was done eight
minutes thirty something that's what it
was good work up that car boom
anyway so if you do kettlebells go to on
it look at there kettlebells
tell me what you think that's all I'm
going to say anyway uh Netcom slash Jaco
get 10% off
on their back to Amazon Amazon
click-through if you like these books
with Musashi
of course yeah Musashi book of five
rings and Musashi the novel by eg
yoshikawa yeah yeah and what that has to
do with Amazon is we have all these
books listed on our website in the book
section top menu books on the podcast
click they're there in order by episode
click on there take you to Amazon that
Amazon link boom you get the book that
supports the podcast and you know any
other shopping you may or may not want
to do boom click through the link good
to go as far support goes small action
huge reaction I know I've said I don't
know why I'm gonna say it what else is
there small action huge reaction
chemically physical change chemical
change tell me are you asking me yes I'm
not gonna answer you just say alright
well I know you know and everyone else
may or may not know but if you don't the
answer is sodium metal when you put it
in water so small piece of sodium I
learn the same 10th grade chemistry put
it in water see what happens
explodes thank you click clear you know
the website figure your amazon stuff the
books or whatever duct tape all that
stuff also good way to support subscribe
to the podcast that's on all of these
things iTunes of course stitcher google
play all the podcasting providing
platforms subscribe goodway's support
leave a review reviews are good yeah
appreciate the reviews yeah very much so
it's fun like one and I don't get bored
but when I'm compelled to read the
reviews it can be very fun to read I
probably read yours if you left one so I
actually read yours if anyone that's
left review I've read it yeah yeah I
think it's like 1300 or something 1400
yeah but I didn't read them all at once
I read them like once every 3-4 days or
if I'm getting ready to record the
podcast I'll I'll go on there and see if
there's any see wouldn't points you have
to take into account yeah the good thing
about and these are iTunes reviews
yeah yeah the good thing about iTunes we
reviews are they're like quality and I
don't mean like oh all necessarily good
or whatever saying quality like you can
tell something like okay here's my
review here's my legit review even if
they're getting nuts with the review and
you're actually helping to because when
you write a review and you kind of let
people know what's up with it what's up
with a podcast then they then they go oh
this sounds like something I should
listen to if they listen to it maybe
they'll get something out of it it
spreads the word so it does help yeah
and let's face it you get more people
following any of these discipline equals
freedom you know making the world better
boilers sharing up let's say thing you
get a room of 10 people you get one guy
do X exhibiting extreme extreme
ownership and then you get another one
same tent or another 10 people you got
10 guys exhibiting a stream ownership
what rooms better the 10 extreme
ownership room just saying so that could
be you when you leave a review and it
affects a mouth full so yeah subscribe
also you can subscribe on youtube if you
are interested in the video version of
this podcast see what Jocko looks like
if you don't know already and you can
see what I look like which you probably
don't know I look different than myself
apparently anyway that's on YouTube also
some excerpts on there right providing
small choco McNuggets of value so you
don't have to share the whole two two
and half hour thing you know with your
friend if you if you like a concept we
can just share the again up to 2 minute
X or three minute whatever you know
shareable so they can watch it and then
go to work rather than be late for work
after listening to two hours potentially
also chocolate is a store it's called
chocolate or chocolate or calm no haiku
there if you are interested in what
t-shirts rash guards will coming out
with some hats here pretty soon
I can't wait to get a hat yeah that's
that's a good though
real good of course yeah it best be yeah
some travel mugs on there good travel
mugs that you know they insulate the
heat apparently that's not like a new
thing knowing are you were amazed by it
I'm still amazed by even though I know
it's not that new of a thing you know
like it I could easily tell you the
story about the ice water I had that
lasted till the next day the ice was
still then I could usually tell you that
I'm not going to waste your time today
nonetheless when you have it boom keeps
the heat in there for like eight hours
and look still like I'm black women
stuff on their shirts of course chuckles
face saying good if you have so the good
video a lot of people seen that video
you know Joe Rogan says good things
about that video some people have
watched that video so essentially that
shirt is that video personified in a
shirt here's a little tip I've said it
before but sometimes people miss this
part of it but good on the bottom is
written backwards you know why because
it's for you when you look in the mirror
that's not that message is not for
everyone else looking at your shirt
that's the chocolate faces for Johnston
face is also for you when you look in
the mirror he's telling you good you
know good will come out of your
situation
I wish say my eight-year-old daughter's
classroom and answer two questions as an
author about weigh the warrior kid and
they have read the way the warrior kid
in the classroom and I gave out I had
bookmarks we have the publisher made
bookmarks that say we had a warrior kid
on one side you know got mark doodle
pull up sure the other side is the
advertisement for discipline equals
freedom Field Manual and that's got my
face on it like the good face sure
iconic and so we handed those out and
one of the kids came up to me and says
you look creepy picture
so of course I said thank you yes yeah
yeah I would say I see what he's getting
at I don't think he look creepy well
tonight honey he did apparently amen
yeah are you allowed to say it's an
iconic picture because you took the
picture kind of I guess technically yeah
I'm allowed to say that but that is not
why I say it okay I say it because I
believe you I believe it is iconic maybe
the point but I think that's actually
what are you and me sit in this room
it's pretty iconic stature it is let
yourself we discount the rest of the
universe and world and maybe we don't
quite do that yeah they're taking one
iconic yeah yeah maybe I'm stretching
the term I don't know it's like when I
went to Kauai that was the shirt that I
wore the most I think that one in the
Jodi medic podcast sure owners they're
both the same color too by the way their
crops yeah man yeah Jaakko store calm
see see what sure you like if you like
any of the show I'm not saying abide by
a shirt or a skewer I'm not saying that
I'm saying go to jacoub store calm take
a look if you like something get
something that supports about gas and
sports yourself you know you get a cool
shirt and or rash guard that's it also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is which I know many people do
but in the event of you not knowing in
this case psychological warfare is an
album with tracks that is available on
iTunes and Amazon music and these places
where you can buy mp3s and albums and
stuff like that
digital music if you will but this isn't
music it's jockle each track is Jaco
telling you why pragmatically by the way
you should not succumb to weakness in
your journey
yeah we're doing dirty records you're
doing journey more so than me yeah we'll
go with it yeah it's yours part here
yeah in your go flow if I were to go
yeah
on your journey in getting after it in
general you're waking up early in the
morning I know that's not easy to do
every
all day you're you know sticking to the
diet special working only bring those
doughnuts right we understand yeah when
you get those lumps in weakness say
you're going to start slacking even just
for one moment you listen to one of
these tracks the appropriate track and
you will and I'll say it's 100% with
100% certainty you will not slack you
will wake up and you will continue there
it is it's like a little spot also you
can get jockle white tea on Amazon
here is a verified purchase review okay
good so this person this is verified
yeah like verified yeah didn't you
understand what they I love their
verified person on Amazon a person this
is a verified review of a person that
actually bought and this is what
happened to told I'm an employee of
Newport News Shipbuilding we build
aircraft carriers and submarines for the
Navy since consuming jock whitey
production has increased substantially
we subsequently delivered two nuclear
aircraft carriers and three nuclear subs
to the Navy while I won't argue that
correlation equals causation I won't say
it's a coincidence either get me so you
know we're talking to you normally it
takes years no four or five years to
build an aircraft carrier
now how they're currently knocking them
out safety day is no factor and again
that's a verified purchase review way to
warrior kid it is also available
wherever you buy books and that one
I got another verified purchase review
there if you're looking for a book for
your kids with a solid message about how
to approach life this is it
the impact is how to my kids is
immediate they asked me if they could do
the same things that the kid does and is
with his uncle in the book the best part
is that they're asking to become more
active training harder at jujitsu
asked about healthier choices for meals
and picking up a book instead of playing
video games it makes a huge difference
when they are the ones making the choice
instead of me making that choice for
them if your kids read just one book
this year this is the one pretty awesome
that just makes me up
super stoked when I hear that kids are
picking up books instead of playing
video games so that's way the warrior
kid also we're actually getting into the
red zone on discipline equals freedom
field manual I'm finishing the final
edits you know this is sort of like my
book of five rings you know to say
unless you wrote that now I'm not on my
deathbed yet hopefully but this is what
I think this is what I do these are the
thoughts actions words of my life when I
workout this is how I work out what food
I eat recovery martial arts and is it
comes out October 17th the cover is done
as a new cover they will they finish the
cover and people were worried because
the original cover they put up this is
just a black cover with it says
disappoint equals freedom Field Manual
by jakka willing that was the original
cover sure that I designed and told them
to post which they did and then there's
been one little addition to that sure
and check it out because some people
because they had originally they had a
stick on there that said cover not final
meaning that people were thinking oh
they're gonna they're gonna make it all
stupid all salesy or whatever but there
was a little addition made to that cover
you can check it out
iconic possibly maybe previous if you
bet really bend and stretch that word
you might be getting there of course
extreme ownership that's the other book
available right now obviously where it
started here combat leadership applied
to the battlefield to business and to
life boom get it also if you need to
support training and transforming your
leadership team wherever you are at your
business your corporation wherever you
are
contact us leadership and management
consulting info at Ashkelon front comm
also the muster austin texas july 13th
and 14th omni Barton Creek Resort now
what's cool of this is basically ending
closed
environment we're in San Diego you know
you can go out you can get around the
omnibar Creek is a little bit outside of
town so it's going to be just us 10 it's
not that huge so it's going to be us
it's going to be we're going to overrun
the place with troopers and it'll be
great
one thing that's not so great is there's
only 300 seats I think we got about 40
or 50 seats left for the Austin muster
so register ASAP there's no room for
expansion in New York we sold out 350 we
expanded the room to 400 we expanded it
to 450 range rearranged stairs there's
no room to do that in Austin so I
apologize if you want to come to Austin
if you're in Austin or if you're in
Texas or wherever you're at you want to
come to that one do it quick WWE xtreme
ownership calm and if it sells out
before you get to see come San Diego
September 14th and 15th muster 0:04 at
the Omni Hotel right in downtown San
Diego and in the meantime if you are
looking to connect with us you can find
us straight-up cruising hard extra hard
extra hard on the interwebs on Twitter
on Instagram and on they face buki EKKO
is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and thanks to everyone for
listening for joining us for supporting
us for subscribing and for spreading the
word and to the military personnel out
there going into harm's way modern-day
samurai warriors protecting our
modern-day Kingdom thank you and the
police law enforcement firefighters EMTs
first responders thanks for being there
when we call you and to the rest of you
out there doing what you do but instead
of just doing it doing it like Musashi
like a warrior excelling in anything and
everything you do
out there getting after it so until next
time this is echo and Jocko out